Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Was mich schon immer mal interessiert, was ist eigentlich dein Lieblingsgetränk.
Mate, Mio, Miomate.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer zweihundertfünfundvierzig vom siebenundzwanzigsten Februar zweitausendachtzehn und der Lebens ist wieder da. Ja. Hallo.
Ja. Hallo. Hallo.
Hallo. Ja, ich äh musste ohne dich klarkommen, aber es hat ganz gut funktioniert letztes Mal.
Ja, hat gut funktioniert, hat gut geklappt, habe ich mich gefreut. Ich freue mich heute mal.
Ja, war eine andere Reiche äh Reise.
Nach Brüssel.
Noch Brüssel.
Jetzt müssen wir aber die Reise hat uns gekostet zwei Wochen deutsche deutsch-russische amerikanische Nachrichten, die wir jetzt hier mal schnell durchprügeln müssen.
Wie ist irgendwas passiert? Ist irgendwas passiert.
Ja, ich war auch überrascht jetzt äh gestern und heute hat sich die Sendung zusammengetragen, habe das doch einiges passiert ist.
Dachte er, solange solange wir noch keine neue Regierung haben, kann man sich auch einfach zurücklehnen, weil da passiert ja eh nichts.
Das haben sich die anderen Regierungen aber nicht gedacht.
Wie fies von ihnen.
Aber wir haben so viel da drin, dass wir noch nicht mal ähm die den politischen Aschermittwoch behandeln werden.
Schlimm. So sind wir.
Ja. Na ja, schauen wir mal. Das überlassen wir anderen.
Na ja, schauen wir mal, was wir denn überhaupt gecovert bekommen. Ich würde sagen, wir äh fangen an mit ein wenig Feedback, denn da gab's welchen.
Welches Feedback ist immer korrekt genannte.
Welches, welches, welches, welches es gab, wo gewesen ist.
Genau, der, wir haben Feedback von Luis. Ähm, ihr habt
auf. Ihr habt auf den Fall der Verstrickung des hessischen Verfassungsschutzes mit dem NSU-Mord an Halit Yozgas in,
Kassel erwähnt. Ähm seit kurzem hat die Initiative NSU-Watch einen eigenen Podcast, könnte man vielleicht bewerben oder bei thematischer Überschneidung mal einladen? Äh wollen wir denn bewerben? Ja, machen wir NSU-Watch, finden wir gut.
Ungehörterweise muss ich's zugeben.
Ich muss den ich habe, muss auch sagen, habe ihn noch nicht gehört, aber die an das Thema ist wichtig und die Ankündigung ist äh da und damit seid, sei euch hier mit der neue Podcast von NSU-Watch zur Prüfung äh empfohlen,
Und wenn wir schon dabei sind, Podcasts zu empfehlen, empfehle ich gleich noch einen ähm.
Es gibt eigentlich so eine Regel, dass man Podcast erst nach zehn erfolgreichen Folgen.
Empfiehlt. Ja, weil viele halten auch nur bis zum neunten durch.
Und der Podcast, den ich jetzt empfehle, hat sich vorgenommen, zweiundfünfzig Folgen zu produzieren.
Ach, das weiß ich schon.
Und ähm das interessante Konzept, diese zweiundfünfzig Folgen rückwärts zu produzieren, das heißt, der beginnt mit Folge zweiundfünfzig und zählt runter,
Und das ist der Podcast von Christian Kessen mit dem schönen Namen Kohlenpott. Und der handelt vom,
Kohlenpott äh dem Ruhrpott also in dem äh am einunddreißigsten zwölften zwanzig achtzehn die letzte Zeche schließen wird und er macht jetzt so jede Woche,
Eine Folge zu dem Thema. Ich habe ihm noch geschrieben, so mache bloß mal ein paar Wochen mehrere und damit du was auf Halde hast, auch eine sehr schöne Halde.
Ja
Ruhrpott Grossage und den kann man einfach mal empfehlen. Das ist sehr schön gemacht. Ähm,
und äh sehr interessant. Manchmal also wirklich merkt er auch selber in den äh in den Kommentaren und im Feedback manchmal ein bisschen schwer zu verstehen, weil es so eine ganz eigene,
Sprache gibt und so viele Begriffe, die jemanden, der nicht aus dem Pott kommt und der nichts mit Kuren Bergboard zu tun hat, echt fremd sind, sodass es tatsächlich manchmal schwierig ist und das finde ich so witzig, weil dann denke ich mir so,
Jetzt weiß ich, wie neue Hörer und Hörerinnen sich bei der Bodenheizpolitik fühl.
Das wollte ich grad sagen.
Und ja hier freundlicher Gruß zum Kohlenport mit Empfehlung. Ähm aber ich muss auch sagen, der wurde inzwischen schon von Bild empfohlen.
Ernsthaft? Ja. Wow.
Habe ich ihm auch gesagt, du, weil du weißt, wen sie hochschreiben, den schreiben sie früher oder später auch wieder runter.
Wie auch immer, wir wünschen äh Glück auf.
Das ist echt mein interessantes äh interessantes Thema. Glück auf, viel Erfolg mit dem Projekt und äh freue ich mich selbst drüber, weil ich da viel über meine Heimat lerne. Meine ehemalig.
Da muss ich aber auch mal hören, dann lerne ich auch mal was über deine Heimat. Na ja, wobei wir hatten ja den den Ding. Also ich hatte ja zumindest den großen Zeh schon ganz tief äh drin, als wir da neulich äh gesungen haben.
Genau, wer ja und da könnt ihr auch so schließt sich nämlich der Kreis, äh, das Steigerlied, äh, was Tim und ich angezettelt haben zur äh zur zu tausend Jahre methodisch inkorrec,
ist nämlich auch das Intro vom Kohlenpott.
Warten wir. Ja. Wie das konkret, was wir gesung.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist ein Klavier am Klavier gespielt. Aber die Melodie.
Ach so, der ist ja natürlich sehr naheliegend. Also ich meine, hätte es irgendein anderes.
Nein, ist der Ruhrpott. Wir haben erliebt, das reicht.
Genau, ihr habt genau eins. Oh Mann, die Vielfalt des Kohlenpotts.
Ja dann ähm.
Haben wir noch mehr Feedback.
Wichtige Ergänzung, wir sind da kurz ins Schwimmen gekommen, als wir über den
dass die der die fremde DNA am Zollstock äh berichtet haben, da erklärt Vincent nochmal den Hintergrund. Äh der verlebes erwähnte Fall, bei dem Fremde DNA durch einen Zollstock an einen Tatortgeach gebudet, war wahrscheinlich der Fund von Uwe Böhnharz,
DNA am Leichenfundort von Peggy Knobloch. Ähm Uwe Böhnhardt,
Einer der Täter des NSU und Peggy Knobloch ein zweitausendeins entführtes,
Mädchen, dessen Skelett ähm Mitte zwanzigsechzehn gefunden wurde. Ähm zwei ähm,
beides Fälle, die eben nachher dann, wie sich eben rausstellte, nix miteinander zu tun hatten,
Aber er empfiehlt außerdem noch äh bei der Diskussion ist auch das Heilbronner Phantom erwähnenswert. Die Polizei sucht zwei Jahre lang nach einer Frau, deren DNA an mehreren Tatorten gefunden wurde. Äh stellt sich raus, dass die,
Wattestäbchen kontaminiert waren. Ähm.
Hab sie uns gerade auch beim Deutschlandfunk zu dem Thema äh zu dem Phantom noch so ein schönes Feature. Ja. Wenn ich auch nochmal raushole.
Können wir auch nochmal raussuchen? Dann kommentiert äh der DTP Leer.
Ähm der Digitalpakt für Schulen,
Denn dafür sollen in den nächsten fünf Jahren fünf Milliarden Euro ausgegeben werden. Das macht bei etwa fünfzigtausend Schulen in Deutschland rund zwanzigtausend Euro pro Jahr und Schule. Wow.
Hashtag D. Ja.
Digitalpark Raute D. Äh da gab's sehr viele sehr viele äh positives Feedback zu dem Lachkrampf. Aber das äh müssen wir jetzt.
War alles echt und war direkt. Oh Mann.
Und dann wendet sich ähm in zwei längeren Kommentaren Jörg an uns. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich die äh vollständig äh,
vorlese. Ähm zum Thema digitale Bildung würde ich euch gerne mal
Eine Wasserstandsmeldung aus der Praxis geben. Ich bin Lehrer an einer beruflichen Schule in Baden-Württemberg, habe Berufsschule aus dem klassischen Handwerk, Meister und Techniker, bin Quereinsteiger und war vorher sechs Jahre in der Industrieforschung. Als ich an die Schule kam, war EDV-Unterricht,
Internetrecherche, Powerpoint oder Cut Schulung äh und etwas für Technikfreaks im Kollegium. Heute fast eineinhalb Jahrzehnte später.
Hat sich das kaum gerechnet? Äh geändert. Noch immer findet der IT-Unterricht
In viel zu kleinen PC-Räumen statt, die knapp sind, gebucht werden müssten, deren Aufsuchen, hochfahren und starten wertvolle Unterrichtszeit kostet. Gleichzeitig haben alle Schüler ihr Smartphone mit prallen Leistungsreserven und alle
Ihre Persönlichkeit erweiternden Apps jederzeit, ohne Zeitverzögerung zur Hand. Und wir Kollegen verschwenden Zeit, ihnen dieses Smoothie Smoothe,
Ich kann dieses Wort einfach nicht aussprechen. Diese Schmusi äh Schnittstelle aus der Hand zu nehmen und sie in die Kabel gebundene
EDV Steinzeit zurückzuzwingen, während wir und die Schüler fleißig per WhatsApp kommunizieren, aber unter uns, den Schülerlehrer, Kommunikation per,
kommerzielle soziale Medien ist in Baden-Württemberg verboten,
Ähm das geht noch lange Zeit weiter, was mich da interessiert äh oder was ich daran interessant finde ist im zweiten Kommentar. Man muss auch ein bisschen bei den Schularten differenzieren. In der eher technikaktiven beruflichen Bildung
Technik affin beruflichen Bildung sind viele Schulen schon recht weit.
Zumal solche, wo der IT-Nachwuchs ausgebildet wird. Da gibt es flächendeckendes WLAN, ganze Tabletklassen, elektronische Stundenpläne und so weiter. Also sehr interessant, ein äh Bericht aus der Praxis. Diese Erfahrung mit der beruflichen,
beruflichen, schulischen Bildung. Äh die habe ich auch. Also da kenne ich,
aus meiner Familie und meiner Erfahrung auch äh berufliche Schulen, die tatsächlich schon vor Jahrzehnten.
Ans Netz gegangen sind und in denen es irgendwie ernst zu nehmenden IT-Unterricht gibt,
BWL und Rechnungswesen dann mit Excel und solchen Dingen, wo also sich mal,
angewandte, beruflich angewandte IT gelehrt wird, äh was äh da dann spätestens auch wirklich,
man auch einfach vor den Schülern und Schülerinnen nicht mehr verheimlichen konnte.
Vor allem, da ist ja auch, sage ich mal, der unmittelbar unmittelbare Bedarf in der Berufsvorbereitung wirklich so klar und da hätte man im Prinzip die Schulen auch gleich schließen können. Wenn sie sich damit nicht haben auseinandersetzen wollen
Wir meinen ja auch was anderes, ne? Wir meinen ja sozusagen überhaupt dieses äh ähm Brace The D, so äh quasi so in in der in der Gedankenkraft. Ich sehe auch ein und auch wenn man so die,
ähm zum Beispiel die Podcast äh aus dieser Szene äh verfolgt, dass er auch nicht unbedingt jetzt eine klare, eindeutige Position vorherrscht, wie es denn nun zu gehen habe,
nur generell zu viel Zögerlichkeit.
Aber da sag
Da sagt der Jörg, nämlich, das finde ich, ist äh sehr wichtigen Punkt. Nur wenn ich Foren, Messenger oder Chatkommunikation im Unterricht selber mit den Schülern praktiziere, kann ich mit ihnen eine Tikette argumentieren mit Quellenangaben, zitieren oder auch das bloße Formulieren von Fragen
deren Illustration und vor allem die eigene Beteiligung am gemeinsamen Prozess näher bringen und vielleicht ein kleines bisschen dazu beitragen
dass sie keine Netzpsychopathen, sondern angenehme Mitbewohner des Global globalen Dorfes werden. Wor.
Ja, wir sind dabei.
Wort, Wort, Entschuldigung, nicht Wort. Wir wollen, wenn dann äh Open Office.
Wie ich mir jetzt nicht ganz so sicher, aber.
Lade ich dann schreibt uns Daniel noch per E-Mail über den Koalitionsvertrag.
Äh dass ihm da noch eine sehr interessante, eine sehr interessante Abschnitt äh aufgefallen ist. Den habe ich auch gesehen, der ist der war aber so skurril äh,
Zur Sicherstellung technologischer Innovationsführerschaft werden wir unter Förderfederführung des Bundesministeriumsministeriums der Verteidigung und des Bundesministeriums des Inneren eine Agentur für disruptive Innovationen in der Cybersicherheit,
Schlüsseltechnologien. Kurz.
Aditsch oder Badic, ne? Äh Bundesagentur für disruptive Informationen in der Cybersicherheit und Schlüsseltechnologie.
Aber du sagst doch auch nicht. Also ich hätt's jetzt mal artig.
Adik? Ja, al.
Also ich habe.
ADIC.
ADC, ADAC und ADIC.
Geht total disruptiv runter.
Also der der Witz ist, ich habe artig DE gesucht, dass zumindest.
Da ist nur irgendein kaputtes PAP zu finden. Äh das ist offenbar nicht das von der.
Badic. Äh und es gibt auf jeden Fall unter die Webseite scheint auf jeden Fall unter BADIC Punkt DE schon ähm im Aufbau zu sein.
Es steht auf jeden Fall die Internetpräsenz der Bundesagentur. Für disruptive Innovation in der Cybersicherheit. Ähm.
Es ist völlig unklar, wie die jetzt im Verhältnis stehen soll zu BSI und Citis.
Und dann irgendwie, warum jetzt auf einmal Innenministerium und Verteidigungsministerium? Also diese jetzt werden die,
Die Interessenskonflikte und die Trennungsgebote aber vollständig aufgehoben, ne? Wir hatten ja schon Inlandsgeheimdienst und Polizei. Äh im Prinzip gemischt in der Zitis. Das reichte offenbar nicht,
man brauchte dann noch das BSI, das ja aber auch der Polizei regelmäßig zur Hilfe gekommen ist, wenn's darum ging, Staatstrojaner äh nochmal zu prüfen. Äh und jetzt brauchen wir halt noch, um den reigen komplett zu machen, brauchen wir halt noch
Verteidigungsministerium und Innenministerium im Interessenskonflikt einer Bundesagentur und dafür jetzt also die.
Fehlt noch, dass die Polizei dann irgendwie mit der Bundeswehr auch noch irgendwie einen Shop aufmacht.
Na ja, die werden sich auf jeden, äh ist, also ist ja theoretisch schon so, ne? Bundesinnenministerium und Bundesverteidigungsministerium haben jetzt zumindest auch noch zumindest auch nochmal eine und dann gibt's außerdem noch ein IT-Sicherheitsfond zum Schutz sicherheitsrelevanter Schlüsseltechnologien
ist alles.
Ein Fonds.
Ja
Wie jetzt Geld?
IT-Sicherheitsfonds raute.
Ich meine Fond, wir reden von Geld.
Vor würdig immer so verstehen, oder? IT.
Ja ich auch. Zum Schutz von Schlüsseltechnologien.
Ja das ist also das es wirklich schwer zu.
Was wie was ist das? Ach so, ist das, ach so, das ist die Kohle, die sie brauchen, um irgendwie die die Zero Days auf dem Schwarzmarkt aufzukaufen.
Mir ist nicht ganz klar, was das soll.
Ja, mir auch nicht. Ich bin mir auch nicht so sicher, ob denen ganz klar ist, was das soll, aber sie machen's offenbar. Ja. Also das genau. Oder sie haben das.
Ja, also da werden, das wird auf jeden Fall es geht auf jeden Fall so absurd los, dass es könnte hat das Potenzial noch absurder als diese Zitis zu werden, die ja schon absurd genug ist.
Wenn die SPD-Mitglieder dafür stimmen? Keine Ahnung, was du da eigentlich irgendwelche Einschätzungen. Wie das so laufen wird.
Na ja, also nachdem äh der Russe sich ja jetzt eingemischt hat.
Das das Thema ziehen wir mal äh direkt an dem Beginn hier das äh.
Passt einfach zu gut, meinst du? Mhm.
Das passt einfach jetzt gerade zu gut, ne? Ähm also was war da wieder los? Ähm die Bild titelte,
Also die diese Papierbild
Ähm das was man noch mitkriegt, weil der Rest ja zum Glück hinter dem Edblocker Blocker äh versteckt ist. Was einer der größten Gefallen ist, sind die Bild mir übrigens hier getan hat, aber die Bildtitelte, neue Schmutzkampagne bei der SPD, es geht um brisante Mails, Kevin Kühnert und ein Mann
namens Juri und äh Juri ist natürlich klar, Juri spielt in diesem Drama den Russen. Der Russe.
Wie sollte er sonst auch hei.
Ja, wie sollte er aus, sonst heißt der,
Und jetzt war die Bild, also offenbar über eine anonyme Quelle an äh E-Mails gelangt, deren Inhalt eben in der deren Inhalt sich in einer Kommunikation zwischen Juri, der unter einer anonym, einer oder mehreren anonymen E-Mail-Adressen firmiert
und Kevin Kühnert äh handelt und Juri bietet also an, ja, wir haben ja die Social Bots.
Kevin Kühnert, der Juso äh Chef, der derzeit in seiner Koalitionsauseinandersetzung im Vordergrund steht, weil er halt gegen die GroKo wettert und dafür wirbt sie nicht zu machen.
Der abtrönige Jungsozialist nee, so heißen sie Sozialisten, ne, das machen die nicht.
Juso halt.
Jungen Sozialdemokraten, oder?
So steht doch für erstmal für so Sozis.
So oder so oder so fallen wir um. Ähm.
Äh nein, also der der junge Mann, der gerade im Prinzip das Gesicht des Widerstandes gegen die Zustimmung der SPD-Basis.
Zum Koalitionsvertrag, der wenn sie denn zustande kommen würde, Weiterführung der Großkoalition ist.
Heißt übrigens wirklich Jungsozialisten? In der SPD.
Können sie dann auch mal ändern? Aber egal. Das ist gar nicht Thema. Äh also Kevin Kühnert kriegt hier in diesem Mailverlauf das Hilfsangebot von einem,
freundlichen Unterstützer namens Juri, der aufgrund verschiedener sprachlichen Barrieren, leider gezwungenes Englisch zu schreiben und bietet ihm also an hier wir haben Social Bots und wir können deine Social,
Mediakampagne uns ist aufgefallen, dass du ja hier, dass deine Kampagne großteils über Social Media passiert und da könnten wir doch helfen.
Und Kevin Kühnert antwortet dann irgendwie so mit, ach ja, so ein paar wir werden hier so ein paar Hashtags verbreiten, da könnten wir auf jeden Fall noch ein paar Social Bots gebrauchen. Beste Grüße Kev.
Und diesen ganzen kleiner Datsch gibt die Bilds äh nimmt die Bildzeitung da äh auseinander und,
titelt dann großflächig, wie immer, also großflächig titelt die Bildzeitung sowieso, denn die Bildzeitung ist insgesamt,
relativ flächiges Medium auf dem relativ wenig,
Buchstaben untergebracht werden. Der heißt den Rest macht man irgendwie vielleicht bekleidete Frauen und großbuchstabige Überschrif.
Erklärst du jetzt unseren digitalen Netz, was eine Zeitung ist.
Bildzeitung. Ich gehe davon aus, dass niemand, der was auf sich hält, sich mit dem Ding näher auseinandergesetzt hat.
Auch der auch der Gemeinde Nörd geht mal morgens zum Bäcker.
Ja, der genau das, was beim Bäcker liegt. So.
Das, was einem beim Bäcker äh,
zeigt, ich hätte doch noch einen Kaffee trinken sollen, bevor ich Brötchen hole. Ja. Bildzeitung also groß, titelt groß, neue Schmutzkampagne bei der SPD,
und die Berichte,
Vorm Bild schießen natürlich überall sonst, also in den seriösen Medien sofort auf eine Skepsis äh weil die äh Mailadresse eine komische Änderung hatte, irgendwie at Jusos DE und Kevin Kühnert wohl eigentlich irgendwo anders agiert. Ähm,
stellte sich raus dieser komplette E-Mail-Austausch a gefälscht,
und zwar von Detitanic. Die äh hier offenbar ähm diese,
diesen kompletten E-Mail-Austausch einfach sich ausgedacht hat und der Bildzeitung unter die Nase gerieben hat. Äh das Bild Zitanik sagt dazu, eine anonyme Mail, zwei, drei Anrufe und die Bild,
alles, was ihn in die Agenda passt. Ähm.
So sieht's aus.
Dann äh haben sie weiterhin noch ein
jemanden interviewt, einen Cyber-Security-Professor und haben ihn irgendwie gefragt, versucht, jemand mit Zugang zum SPD-Netz Kevin Kühner zu schaden oder wurde ein SPD-Computer von Hackern missbraucht ähm.
Titanic antwortet, nein, es versucht jemand mit Copy und Paste die journalistische Qualität der Bild zu überprüfen. Ähm.
Es gibt jetzt in der Bewertung eine relativ,
Es gibt zwei Arten darauf zu blicken. Es gibt natürlich einerseits diejenigen, die mit Helme darüber lachen, dass die Bildzeitung mal wieder. Das ist ja jetzt auch nicht das erste Mal, dass die Bild und ihre Methoden ähm,
entlöst werden, ganz im Gegenteil, dafür gibt es ein eigenes Blog, das Bildblock, das täglich deren fälschliche und überspitzte und hetzerische Darstellung auseinander nimmt. Ja, es ist jetzt nicht,
Ein Einzelfall, das mal durch irgendwie in zehn Jahren bei der, bei der Bild äh unredliche Berichterstattung bemängelt wird oder so. Nein, das ist etwas tägliches bei denen,
und da lachen natürlich viele inklusive mir. Ähm sehr hemisch drüber, äh dass das jetzt nochmal in diesem äh Rahmen,
auch gezeigt wurde, dass sie eben keinem journalistischen Anspruch genügen und eben mit Agenda äh Hetze fahren.
Ähm es gibt aber andere äh unter anderem denen von mir geschätzten Jakob Augstein, der äh das auch sehr stark kritisiert und sagt, das, was die Titanic da getan hat.
Das gehört sich nicht. Man täuscht nicht eine äh.
Einen Journalisten absichtlich arglistisch und das Argument, was er oder ich glaube, was er der größtenteils äh zu äh sagt, ist, dass,
Der Schaden quasi der angerichtet wurde, dadurch, dass dieser
Unsinn einen Tag lang bei jedem Bäcker lag, den wird die Titanic quasi nicht einholen können, ja? Also es gibt jetzt irgendwelche Menschen, die beim Bäcker waren und gesehen haben, der Kühnert kooperiert mit den Russen,
gegen die GroKo,
die daraus irgendwelche Schlüsse ziehen werden und die im Zweifelsfall nicht mehr mitbekommen, dass das Ganze eigentlich von einem Titanikredakteur äh,
Namens Moritz Hüttgen als Scherz.
Was im Wesentlichen ja auch daran liegt, dass die Bildzeitung nicht bereit ist, äh in der selben Sichtbarkeit äh äh mal ein paar Tage später auch mal klarzustellen, dass dem nicht so ist.
Na, da, also das weiß ich noch nicht mal genau, ob die das so ob die das tun. Ich bin da nur sehr überrascht ähm über die oder sehr ähm amüsiert, über die Einlassung von Julian Reichelt auf Twitter. Julian Reichelt ist,
Seit Februar zweitausendsiebzehn Vorsitzender der Chefredaktion und Chefredakteur Digital der Bild Zeitung und er wird nach dem Ausscheiden von Tanet Koch im März zweitausendachtzehn also,
sehr bald, auch die Position des Chefredakteurs, der Printausgabe der Bildübernehmen. Also das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal so der neue,
Kai Dieckmann und jemand, der irgendwie die Nachfolge von Kai Dieckmann antritt und.
Da ist natürlich da musst du schon aus einem ganz besonderen Holz sein und ganz besondere ähm.
Werte vertreten, die für einige andere vielleicht gar nicht so einfach nachvollziehbar sind.
Werte gesagt.
Werte, aber hat auch den gleichen Bart.
Julian Reichelt und äh hier.
Oh
Ja. Oh man. Okay, aber dann, das finde ich also sehr schön.
Dieser Bildredakteur, äh Bildchefredakteur lässt sich dann auf einmal eine Bild, die bei denen selten eine Artikel mehr als hundertvierzig Zeichen hat, äh lässt sich jetzt irgendwie zu,
mehrere äh so ein Tweetstorm, so einen Trump, ein
Tweetstorm hin, in dem er dann eben gesagt, einmal zur Einordnung der Titanikgeschichte. Wir haben nie von einer Kampagne von
Kevin Kühn hat geschrieben, dafür aber von einer Kampagne gegen ihn. Berichtet haben wir nachdem die SPD Strafanzeige äh gestellt hat. Äh Bild woll
Titanic wollte Bild in mehreren Versuchen eine klare Fest in eine klare Festlegung treiben, dass Kevin Kühnert mit russischen
Personen kooperiert. Das haben wir nie getan, sondern immer nur die Position der SPD dargelegt und explizit geschrieben, dass diese plausibel ist. Der SPD haben wir stets alle gewünschten Infos zur Verfügung gestellt
Alle Details werde ich gleich,
dokumentieren, meine Meinung, natürlich darf Satire so etwas, aber sie versucht, sich hier zu profilieren, indem sie eine journalistische Arbeit
bewusst zu diskreditieren versucht. Unser Kollege la hat in seiner Vergangenheit immer wieder großartige und wichtige
Geschichten zum Thema Desinformation,
Ja, würde ich auch sagen, recherchiert. Ach so und war aufgrund seiner Erfahrung skeptisch, la la. Er wirst du interessant, also das war länger als jeder äh Artikel in der Bildzeitung jemals.
Und ich finde, finde es interessant zu sehen, wie der jetzt auf einmal Sachen einordnen muss, ja? Der redet da auf einmal der Bildchefredateur von einer bewussten Diskreditierung, ja.
Es muss jetzt aufgeklärt werden
dass die dass die dass die die Titanic sich hier profilieren musste und das muss man hier irgendwie hier klargestellt werden und so, ne? Und da fragst du dich ernsthaft so, wann
haben die das jemals für eines ihrer täglichen Opfer getan, ja?
Das ist so, das ist so.
Selbstgerecht.
Beärmlich und selbstgerecht, was was dieser Mensch da abzieht. Dass man, da muss man einfach sagen, da musst du doch da musst du doch auch irgendwie ernsthaft so stehen, musst du sagen, ja klar,
Wir sind Drecksschweine, das hat für uns gereicht. Er trüffelt Schweine, Entschuldigung, da habe ich mich vertan. Wir sind Trüffelschweine und diesen äh Trüffel konnten wir, ne, Entschuldigung, niemals für dich,
die Bildzeitung als Drecksschweine bezeichnen? Nein, das ist äh Trüffelschweine. Und ähm.
Der Typ kriegt sich auch gar nicht mehr ein, ja? Der der twittert heute noch, ne? Also die gebellten Hunde äh die die getroffenen Hunde bellten noch monatelang in der Nacht, ja
gegen den Mond, den das überhaupt nicht interessiert. Aber am meisten regt er sich darüber auf, dass der
Moritz Hürtgen dann noch ein Fernsehinterview zu diesem Thema gegeben hat und wem gibst du
Zu diesem Thema ein Fernsehinterview. Ganz klar, es kommt nur ein Sender in Frage, den du als allererstes sofort dazu natürlich ein Interview gibst.
Warte mal kurz, Moritz Fürth, geh mal jetzt Wern.
Titanikredakteur, der das gemacht hat. Was ist der, welcher Fernsehsender? Welchen Fernsehsender gibst du als allererstes,
Ein TV-Interview, wenn du als Titanik-Redakteur äh den die Bild davon überzeugt hast, dass es eine russische Verschwörung um Kevin Kühnert gibt.
Retweet Fernsehen. RT.
Russia Today, natürlich.
Und jetzt kann man sich irgendwie seit Wochen, äh ne, seit Tagen kann man sich also angucken. Wie ausgerechnet Julian Reichelt. Ähm das Trüffelschwein der Nation, ja,
Ähm sichaufiert, das ist eine Desinformationskampagne gab,
ausgerechnet Russia Today, was ja so, also absolut diese diese Hetzer und die überhaupt keine journalistischen Standards und das wäre ja Putins Haus, Sender und du Dings hier um diese äh.
Ey, kann ich nur empfehlen. Julian Reichelt auf Twitter.
Also das ist wirklich.
Oh, liebe Titanic, danke. Bitte, also ich find's einfach immer wieder bemerkenswert mit welcher.
Größe und Weizen agieren wir mal ganz ehrlich hier diese ganze Kritik mit na ja wie kann man denn nur die Presse äh vorführen und so weiter ey auch die Presse braucht Kontrolle,
und äh das wir sowieso schon so oft auf Satiremagazin zurückgreifen müssen, um irgendwie noch äh halbwegs mentale Sanity an Start zu bekommen. Ist ja schon bedrückend genug.
Außerdem hat uns die Titanic die Weltmeisterschaft gegeben. Das tun wir niemals vergessen.
Oh, da haben.
Das hätte der Franz alleine nicht hinbekommen.
Aber du kennst auch den hinter diese diese Story noch, ne? Als die Titanic das nämlich gemacht hat. Es geht hier darum, dass die Titanic äh als es um die Vergabe der.
Fußballweltmeisterschaf.
Fußballweltmeisterschaften haben die Picknickkörbe an einige der von Ländergesandten äh von den von den unterschiedlichen internationalen,
FIFA Mitgliedern haben die den Picknickkörbe geschickt. Mit freundlichen Grüßen der deutschen Delegation. Was dazu geführt hat, dass,
die eben dann sich enthalten haben, weil sie die so und äh als die Titanic das öffentlich gemacht hat, hat die Bildzeitung sich.
Wieder einen Trüffel gefunden, ja und hat eine eine riesige,
ähm äh Lobhuldigungen der satirischen Qualität der Bildzeitung gemacht, ja. Und hat dann da unter anderem irgendwie die Telefonnummer der Redaktion angegeben
Äh was so ein Bildleser sich natürlich nicht zweimal sagen lässt. Er hat ja den Bildmobiltarif und kann ja.
Hat eine Roundflatrate.
So und die Titanic hat einfach nur den Anrufbeantworter angemacht und hat nachher den kompletten Anrufbeantworter einfach online gestellt. So, wo du dann irgendwie diese ganzen Bildlaser hattest, die dann da quasi ihre äh,
Einschätzung dieser Aktion der Titanic äh nochmal auf Band äh rezitiert haben,
Und genau so ist jetzt irgendwie dieser äh dieser reichelt ah, der ist jetzt seit Tagen ähm dabei irgendwie diese diese Bildleser gegen.
King, ähm denen ging die Titanic aufzuhetzen, könnte mir vorstellen, dass da demnächst nochmal spannende,
Anrufbeantworter Nachrichten und Leserbriefe an die Bild äh erscheinen werden. Spitze jetzt Gameboy oder was?
Ne, das äh wollte nur kurz das noch das Geräusch abspielen, was bei der Titanic immer ist, wenn solche Berichte kommen. Dann macht's halt immer so, ne?
Also eine Aktion, ja.
Aber interessant, das wäre mal spannend. Genau, das machen wir jetzt hier äh als Frage.
Da würde mich eure Meinung zu interessieren ob das jetzt in Ordnung war oder nicht ich würde vorsichtig sagen es ist vieles nicht in Ordnung das hier ist wenigstens witzig. Das ist ja so meine äh meine.
Also, sagen wir mal so, ich würde es mal anders formulieren. Ähm bei aller Berechtigten Kritik vielleicht generell betrachtet, ähm,
Wenn wir schon an dem Punkt sind, dass wir sozusagen uns jetzt ausgerechnet bei der Bild-Zeitung irgendwie äh darüber unterhalten, wohin wir,
Wie man den Journalismus denn beschützen musste, würde ich irgendwie dann doch eher mal woanders anfangen, ja? Also,
Das ist jetzt nicht so unbedingt jetzt die Zeitung, die den ersten Stein äh werfen sollte.
Vor allem nicht Steine wie guten Morgen Titanic. Tag zwei, nachdem ihr eure Zusammenarbeit mit Ertheke aufgenommen habt und euer Kollege äh Hürtgen für einen schnellen Bildgag im Lieblingssender von Holocaust Leugning und
holen und kosten, leugnen und Verschwörungstheoretikern aufgetreten ist, hat er dafür jetzt eigentlich Geld genommen? Sexy so, Alter wie für
dumm hältst du eigentlich deine eigene Leser.
Das sind doch alles Weicheier beier dabei Bild. Mal ehrlich. Ihr könnt dann nix ab.
Ja, das Problem.
Zeigt mal ein bisschen größer irgendwie. Wer so stark austeilt, muss auch mal eins stecken können.
Kann, muss auch mal zwischendurch kurz einstellen können, ja.
Ja echt Lema.
Getroffene Hunde bellen und hier das ist wirklich ein ein äh.
Erfrischendes.
Eine erfrischend armseliges Gejaune.
Darauf eine Matte.
So, kommen wir zu weiteren Sachen, die nicht hier in Ordnung sind, aber vielleicht weniger witzig. Ähm.
Genau, ach ja. Und Trojaner.
Liebe Hörer schafft das Sachen wird euch schon noch vergehen, denn äh wie Eric Möchel ähm,
in einer ausgeführten Recherche bei FM vier berichtet. Erich Möchel hier schon regelmäßig erwähnt eigentlich der der Pate des netzpolitischen Journalismus äh Gründer der Future Zone in äh Österreich aktiv und
Inzwischen bei FM vier schreibt das nämlich,
Finn zwei, also das Produkt aus dem Hause Gamma Finn Fischer. Äh Staatstrojaner in Deutschland wird. Und zwar haben wir äh in Deutschland eigentlich diesen selbstentwickelten Trojaner namens RC IS
Remote Control Interception Software geplant und auch zweitausendsechzehn schon zugelassen. Wir hatten darüber auch ausführlich berichtet. Aber es gab ähm.
Daran ausführliche äh Kritik der Strafverfolger, die sagten, äh das funktioniert nur auf Windows und nur mit Skype, aber wir haben ja irgendwie hier eher so ein Problem mit Android, IOS und äh WhatsApp,
ja und äh da muss jetzt mal was passieren und äh ja, stellt sich raus, da kauft man natürlich bei denen ein, die damit Erfahrung haben, Erfahrung haben jene, die in Ländern,
verkaufen, die bei den
Hacking der eigenen äh Bürger und Dissidenten nicht so lange äh parlamentarischer äh und höchstrichterlicher Kontrolle unterliegt, sondern die ja, sage ich mal, einen gewissen Vorsprung haben. Und das sind natürlich,
die als Diktaturen und Demokraturen bekannten Republiken und Staaten wie zum Beispiel,
Türkei, Ägypten unter Mobarak,
Saudi-Arabien, ne? Also die alle, die quasi in dem die uns einfach ein bisschen weiter voraus sind.
Vereinigte Arabische Immerate.
Ja, so die ganzen.
Diese eine etwas andere Auffassung haben als wir, was so Freiheit und äh Schutzwürdige Infrastruktur et cetera betrifft.
Ja und Ina hat vor allem äh auch irgendwie,
Viel größere Staatsfeinde haben äh gegen die sie dann vorgehen müssen, zum Beispiel Ahmed Mansur, der äh irgendwie äh also es ist auch wirklich äh irre, also an dem haben die ein so großes Interesse, dass sie ihn dann, dass sie ein Ahmed man so inzwischen drei,
Staatstrojaner Hersteller verfeuert haben, nämlich Gammafin Fischer, äh das Produkt aus dem Hause,
Deutschland und Großbritannien, ja? Also die deutsch-britische Gamma Group hat,
eine GmbH in München und zwei Unternehmen in England und dann natürlich nochmal Resellerunternehmen in den einzelnen Ländern, um die Exportrestriktionen äh zu umgehen,
Und dann gibt es noch die das Unternehmen Hacking Team aus Italien und die NSO NSO Group
aus Israel. Und alle drei äh,
Hersteller wurden oder alle drei Produkte wurden inzwischen äh an äh ihm verfeuert, ja. Äh der äh wo dann jedes Mal der die Zugesandte Myware äh durch das City sind Lab,
kanadische,
Freie Forschungseinrichtungen unter Ronald Deibert äh analysiert und veröffentlicht wurde. Zweitausendelf, zweitausendzwölf und zweitausendsechzehn haben sie immer wieder an den armen Typen geschickt äh und interessant.
Jedes Mal.
Jedes Mal dazu geführt, dass wir relativ viel,
Informationen über diese Staatstrianer Hersteller hatten die an auch jeweils beim Kongress präsentiert wurde.
Das heißt, das ist irgendwie der Begriff Honipot wird dann direkt, äh, wird dann demnächst unbenannt in Mansur,
Ich halte einfach mein Telefon hoch und dann habt ihr wieder was zum Analysieren. Nicht schlecht.
Interessant ist natürlich, also immer wieder der Typ ist natürlich kein Krimineller, sondern er ist ein oppositioneller äh gegen den äh aus politischen Gründen vorgegangen wurde.
Allem Journalist, ne? Bei Alja Zira.
Ja also reicht ja für die Bezeichnung als Oppositioneller, ne.
Ja, stimmt.
Da sehen wir also wo diese Unternehmen ihre Expertise gesammelt und aufgebaut haben ähm und.
Welche mit welchen Unternehmen sich nun hier auch die Bundesrepublik gerne einlässt.
Das ist sehr hm dramatisch und sehr bedauerlich, dass das geschieht. Ähm denn solche Unternehmen sollten natürlich eigentlich.
An dem, was sie tun, gehindert werden und nicht noch unterstützt werden. Und wenn wir ähm als Bundesrepublik das Vorgehen äh gegen Journalisten gegen,
Disidenten äh und das Vorgehen gegen die Meinungsfreiheit,
kritisieren und zurecht kritisieren und die Meinungsfreiheit hochhalten dann sollten wir selbstverständlich nicht.
Diese hm diese Vorgehensweisen.
Ähm unterstützen, ja und vor allem nicht mit den gleichen Unternehmen, die dies ermöglichen,
Kooperieren. Das ist eine sehr äh traurige, aber ebenso vorhersehbare Nachricht. Wir haben darüber äh schon länger äh hier berichtet, unter anderem auch als Andre Meister damals bei Netzpolitik Orgli,
liegte, dass es eben ein Kooperationsvertrag äh zwischen der deutschen Bundesregierung und,
Gammafin Fischer gab ähm zu äh die vor hunderttausend Euro zur Prüfung der Software gezahlt wurden äh um dann dem Unternehmen zu helfen ein Produkt zu kreieren, dass,
den rechtlichen Anforderungen in Deutschland übereinstimmen würde.
Das tun diese Standardprodukte von diesen Unternehmen auf gar keinen Fall und offenbar ist das jetzt am Ende gekommen und äh dieses Produkt wird jetzt in Deutschland zum Einsatz kommen. Das ist nicht.
Äh
Bei Netzpolitik Org gibt's äh auch eine ganze Reihe von Artikeln über Finnfischer. Ähm,
nicht nur das, was du erwähnt hast, sondern einfach viel Dokumentation, wo diese Software eingesetzt wird, et cetera PP.
Wir hatten auch also wir haben im über Gamma und Finn Fischer immer wieder hier berichtet, die hatten auch vor ein paar Jahren ein League aus ihrem Support-Forum, wo dann auch nochmal Länder bekannt wurden, äh in denen das zum Einsatz kam. Hm, da haben wir damals viel dran,
herum analysiert und da wurde auch viel berichtet.
Zumindest mal on paar mit den ganzen Bösewichter.
Ja, der liegt, der liegt bei Gamma war einer, der am wenigsten ertragreichen, weil die sehr viel relevante Dinge immer noch mal PGP verschlüsselt hatten. Das heißt, der Hacking-Team League war sehr, sehr viel,
ertragreicher für die Freiheit als der Gammer-League. Leider.
Es steht weiterhin diese Unternehmen und ihre unmoralischen Geschäftsgebaren zu ächten und nicht sie zu fördern und diese Chance hat unsere Bundesregierung hier äh vertan.
So und jetzt? Nächstes Thema, oder? Ach so.
Nächstes Thema, oder?
Wir sind wir alle. Tim, du bist AfD.
Wir alle. Wir alle. Wir alle sind AfD. Du bist AfD. Ja, sogar ich. Sogar ich bin AfD, ich hab's nicht gewusst, aber da gab's ja Gott sei Dank eine Webseite, äh wo man sich da entsprechend informieren kann.
Also in einem muss ich sagen, einem der schlimmsten Fehlurteile, die ich in den letzten Jahren gesehen habe.
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall zweifelhaft.
Also ein junger äh ein junger Student,
hat unter der DE Domain wir Minus sind minus AfD Punkt DE eine Webseite unterhalten,
In der er rassistische, rechtsextreme und Menschenverachtende Zitate der AfD sammelt,
wenn man diese Seite besucht, steht da, wir sind AfD, dann ist daneben ein, so ein Daumen nach unten in rot, der sofort klar zu erkennen macht, dass man hier nicht auf der Seite der AfD gelandet ist und dann steht dort für diejenigen, die's, also es sollte dann.
Na ja, also hier besteht natürlich noch so ein bisschen ähm,
Die Gefahr, dass man die Satire nicht erkennt als AfD-Anhänger, denn da steht, wir sind eine rechtsextreme rassistische, menschenverachtende Partei und wir sitzen unter anderem im Deutschen Bundestag, da müsste man, das könnte man jetzt nochmal kennzeichnen mit Achtung.
Weil der normale AfD äh Supporter sich dann denkt, so ja.
Ja, genau, der könnte ja jetzt nicht, also ja, also daran.
Und das stimmt ja auch sonst alles, was da, was da so steht,
Ja, von daher weiß ich gar nicht, worüber sie sich groß aufregen. Also das Ganze ist eigentlich eine eine Liste von so den Haarsträubensten Äußerungen verschiedenster Vertreter der AfD,
und auch nicht so sehr viel mehr. Ne, also diese Webseite macht eigentlich relativ klar, worum es hier geht,
behauptet aber auch nicht unbedingt groß ähm,
Jetzt selbst die AfD zu sein, also es ist jetzt nicht so ein Copycat-Projekt, äh was einfach versucht, da die Webseite nachzubauen und irgendwie so, klar, man findet hier die Farben wieder
et cetera aber noch nicht mal das Logo.
Also es ist relativ erkennbar, dass diese Webseite nicht von der AfD betrieben wird. Ähm, gleichzeitig hier natürlich diese Zitate der AfD sammelt, ähm.
Ich denke, das ist relativ eindeutig, dass es sich hierbei um ein Produkt der Meinungsfreiheit äh handelt,
und ähm sehr erstaunlicherweise ähm wurde dieser Fall. Also die AfD hat sich äh dagegen zur Wehr gesetzt,
und hat auf Unterlassung äh und Freigabe der Domänen,
geklagt und das Landgericht Köln hat am neunten Februar äh entsprechend geurteilt, ja. Denn äh und zwar sagt das Landgericht, äh dass der Domainname die Namensrechte der Parteialternative für Deutschland verletzt,
Ähm und das ist sehr interessant, weil das musst du, das ist,
Also es gibt in diesem Domainrecht, ist jetzt irgendwie auch ein kleinen letzten Tag nochmal mit anderen Juristen auch unterhalten. Äh das da gibt's einschlägige Rechtssprechung und es gibt da eben ähm.
Immer mal wieder Auseinandersetzungen mit Marken mit Marken
Rechten, die verletzt werden oder auch mit sogenannten Domain Grabbern, die also Domänen, Domains registrieren, um sie nachher den.
Denen für die sie interessant sind, irgendwie teuer zum Verkauf anzubieten und so ist auch eine sehr ähm sehr geniale, tolle Art äh Geld zu verdienen, ne? Da gibt's also einstige Rechtssprechung.
Und entscheidend ist hier ähm für dieses Urteil die Zuordnungsverwirrung,
Also ist es denkbar, dass eine Zuordnungsverwirrung stattfindet und wenn das der Fall ist, dann stehst du eben mit deiner mit deiner Domain auf dünnem Eis. Ja, also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel die Domain AfD DE,
betreiben würdest, ja, dann wäre es also relativ einfach
zu argumentieren, dass jemand der nach der AfD sucht, AfD DE eingibt und dann nicht bei der bei dir und du, die ihn dann quasi arglistig täuscht und dass es zu Ende, dass du eine Zuordnungsverwirrung absichtlich in Kauf nimmst und äh so weiter, ja
Ähm weil wir sind AfD DE ist das aber natürlich eher nicht der Fall. Möchte ich mal vorsichtig,
argumentieren. Ähm.
Aber das äh das Landgericht Köln argumentiert hier äh anders und hat dieses äh Urteil.
Gefällt und zwar.
In einer Form, die noch zunehmend relativ hart ist, weil sie sagen ähm ihm wird also jetzt untersagt zu.
Zu zweihundertfünfzigtausend Euro Ordnungsgeld oder alternativ Haftstrafe, wenn er die Domain weiterhält und betreibt,
Er muss sie also löschen, er muss außerdem eintausenddreihundert Euro neben Zinsen an den Kläger, also an die AfD zahlen und die Kosten des Rechtsstreits übernehmen.
Und ähm jetzt ist das aber nur teilweise direkt vollstreckbar, weil das äh weil man dagegen wohl äh vorgehen kann. Also es ist noch nicht rechtskräftig, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe.
Nee, da kann man jetzt nochmal gegen vorgehen.
Ja, kann man jetzt nochmal gegen vorgehen und das wird natürlich auch passieren. Und da gibt's dann eine schöne Spendenseite, ähm die wir auch verlinkt haben,
wo der äh Betreiber dieser Seite äh Natan äh Geld äh,
in oder wo für ihn gesammelt wird von einer Freundin und nahmen inzwischen zweitausendeinhundertsechsundzwanzig Beteiligungen dazu geführt, dass er jetzt ein Guthaben von fünfundfünfzigtausend Euro hat, um sich gegen diesen,
Quatsch zur Wehr zu setzen und das ist auch richtig und wichtig, denn dieses Urteil ist,
nicht korrekt und wenn dieses Urteil äh irgendwie äh Schule machen würde, dann äh ist es bald einfach nicht mehr möglich, Kritik an Unternehmen, an Parteien und sonstigen,
sinnvoll zu äußern, wenn diese irgendwie in der Domain nicht mehr vorkommen dürfen. Ja, also das ist.
Das geht gar nicht und,
äh wenn man jetzt den äh Einschätzungen anderer äh rechtsgelehrter glauben darf, äh ist das auch nicht so ohne weiteres zu halten, dieses Urteil, also die Chancen stehen da durchaus.
Äh gut, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, hat sie jetzt schon auf äh Thomas Starters, Artikel äh verwiesen.
Der erklärt das nochmal ausführlicher,
Der Stand ist nicht fünf einundfünfzigtausend, sondern fünfundfünfzigtausend, das war der Tipp von von offenbar gestern, der auch noch offen war. Also da kommt gut was zusammen und das ist auch wichtig, hier jetzt eine klare Kante zu zeigen
denn sowas irgendwie rauszuklagen ist man wirklich, also
das kann man uns kann man sich nicht gefallen lassen und hier geht's äh nicht nur darum, dass es die AfD ist, die sich das hier bitteschön gefallen lassen soll, sondern dass solche Satireseiten eben
notwendiger ein Bestandteil der politischen Auseinandersetzung sind und äh solche Scherze können wir uns nicht verbieten lassen. Geht einfach nicht,
und die muss man übrigens auch über sich ergehen lassen, ja? Wenn das jemand äh mit.
Uns macht, ja, dann kann man eben von mir aus dagegen vorgehen, wenn.
Wir sind LNP.
Ja, wir sind LMP. Ja, könnte jetzt jemand machen, gut, wenn die Leute die Zeit dafür haben, dann ist das eben so
zur Wehr setzen, kann man sich gegen Ehrverletzende Behauptungen und interessanterweise scheint die AfD hier an der Behauptung wir sind Menschen verharrten, so gar nicht so viel auszusetzen gehabt zu haben.
Das passt ihm auch ganz gut im Kram,
Ja, nee, also ihr könnt gerne unsere Zitate weiter veröffentlichen und größeren Menschengruppen zugänglich machen. Wir stehen ja dazu, wie das die AfD mit ihren Äußerungen oder zumindest mit den Äußerungen einzelner äh so seine Probleme haben sollte, ist glaube ich auch klar,
dass sie das nicht haben ist nochmal ein Skandal extra obendrauf, aber wir werden jetzt mal eben mal sehen, wie gut die sich äh schlagen im Bundestag kriegen sie ja schon mal ganz ordentlich aufs Maul. Ähm, ich hoffe, das bleibt auch so
und dann werden wir ja mal sehen, ob man nicht diesen ganzen Diskurs mit ähm,
Idiotie nicht auch nochmal so schön auf die Spitze treiben kann, dass vielleicht auch mal ein paar Leute zur Besinnung kommen, die äh sich hier haben von anderen Themen ablenken lassen und äh durch Skategoting sozusagen zu verlinken haben.
Ja, äh, Leuten macht Fülle zu geben und Einfluss auf Teile unseres Staates zu geben, die,
einfach nicht, gerade was ich nicht für eine gute Idee halte, ja? Also allein wenn äh ich meine sie sind zwar jetzt nicht irgendwie, sie stellen nicht.
Den Kanzler oder die Kanzlerin, das würden sie wahrscheinlich auch nie tun, ne, so werden das nicht nur den Kanzler. Nur weil die AfD würde wahrscheinlich eher den Führer stellen wollen.
Gauland.
Aber schon so auf niedrigerer Ebene in irgendwelchen Kulturausschüssen zu sitzen, die über Geldverteilung für Theater, et cetera andere freigeistige Organisationen zu entscheiden haben, kann schon zu Problemen führen und deswegen sollte man sie eben so klein halten, wie es nur irgendwie geht.
Dann und es ist insbesondere in dem Zusammenhang ist natürlich sehr interessant, wenn man sich überlegt, dass hier dieser Andre Poggenburg am politischen,
Aschermittwoch eine äh also wieder also der hat ja was, der ist mir ja echt die Spucke weggeblieben, was der ähm.
Für eine Rede gehalten hat, äh den er irgendwie über äh,
Kümmelhändler und Kameltreiber herzieht und also äh also wirklich einfach etwa so ein dermaßen äh,
sowas von daneben und er beruft sich dann aber natürlich sehr frei und schnell, ja, das war ja eine zugespitzte Politsatire und äh ist ja wieder klar, dass man dass man uns hier den politischen Aschermittwoch
nicht gönnt, ja? Also das ist der berufen sie sich gerne auf Satire, ne? Aber wenn.
Meinungsfreiheit.
Wenn ihnen ihre, wenn ihnen ihre äh eindeutig einfach mal,
nichts satirischen Äußerungen in dieser Menge äh vorgehalten werden, da sofort äh
quasi alle Mittel in Bewegung setzen. Das ist schon das ist offen ähnlichen äh Niveau wie hier dieser Julian Reich hält, ne.
Aber komm wundert mich jetzt auch wiederum nicht.
Wird jetzt die Bild-Zeitungschef-Redaktion noch nicht so ganz in der Abteilung. AfD verlagern wollen. Ähm, von daher kann man vielleicht auch nochmal trennen.
Völlig in Ordnung. Wir ganz klare Trennung von äh Partei und Organ. Nein, der Punkt ist einfach, wenn du, wenn du
wer austeilen kann, muss auch einstecken können und wenn du ähm dich selber mit mit ganz klarer
Hassrede auf politische Satire berufst, dann ist es natürlich sehr überraschend, wenn du eine weitere politische äh Satire, die eigentlich nur deine Hassrede wiedergibt, äh dass dieses Recht abspricht
das ist erstaunlich.
Na gut, schalten wir in die USA. Ähm da wird äh weiterhin ähm ein bisschen aufgeräumt.
Da wird richtig aufgeräumt.
Das kleine göllische Dorf in großen Ganzen äh Wahnsinn, der da gerade äh stattfindet, ist ja die laufende Untersuchungskommission,
äh im FBI angeführt durch den ehemaligen FBI-Chef,
Robert Möller, der irgendwie eine bemerkenswerte Performance an den Tag legt. Also ähm einerseits haben die halt,
Team, was offensichtlich in alle Richtungen forscht so und auch wenn's halt zunächst einmal um die äh Einflussnahme die mögliche Einflussnahme von Russen im Wahlkampf,
ging oder immer noch geht natürlich auch ähm wird zunehmenden Maße breit geschaut und es wird vor allem auch auf
mit einer interessanten Strategie im Wochenabstand werden immer wieder so kleine Bündchen,
geworfen, die tatsächlich dann immer wieder ganz interessante äh Implikationen haben, ne. Also es fing damit an, dass Leute.
Ähm ich muss gerade nochmal die Reihenfolge äh.
Los mit Manafort, finde ich das richtig in Erinnerung.
Ja, es ging mit meiner Frau dessen, was vorgeworfen wurde, dann wurde ihm,
ähm also er wurde angeklagt, aber er hat nichts zugegeben. Danach kamen dann aber wiederum Leute, die,
wo dann klar wurde, dass sie definitiv ihre Schuld schon eingestanden haben, dass sie nämlich gegenüber dem FBI-Fairtrade Falschaussagen gemacht haben und andere äh falschen Sachen gemacht haben und dass sie da einen Deal eingegangen sind
jüngst wurden dann auch nochmal Leute angeklagt
die eben da sozusagen nicht mitspielen wollten und die dann nochmal so extra was auf den Deckel bekommen haben. Ich will jetzt nicht die komplette Timeline hier runterbeten, allein schon, weil ich sie nicht auswendig kann, aber so kriegt man das mit
also der das Spiel, was hier gespielt wird, ist ganz klar, wenn wir mit euch reden. Sagt die Wahrheit, ja,
Wir wissen unter Umständen schon viel mehr als ihr hofft, ja und wenn ihr irgendwo daneben legt, dann machen wir euch sofort platt,
Und wir haben auch überhaupt gar keine
Zurückhaltung mehr, wir schauen eure finanziellen Transaktionen, wir schauen irgendwie in euer ganzes Geschäftsgebahren, wir kennen irgendwie das Freundesgeflecht, wir wissen wie oft ihr irgendwie schon in Russland bei irgendwelchen Uligarchen auf dem Boot rumgesessen habt, irgendwie äh,
bückt euch und das macht schon diesen ganzen Trumpaparat extrem nervös.
Ähm Hintergrund der ganzen Sache ist natürlich immer der das Ziel dieser,
Ermittlungen oder war äh ist den Leuten den kleinen Fischen einen Deal anzubieten? Also im Prinzip Strafminderung oder Straffreiheit gegen
Kronzeugenaussage gegen wichtigere Fische wie es in der US-Justiz glaube ich sehr viel
gebräuchlicher und einfacher möglich ist als in Deutschland.
Ja, also Grundzeugenregelungen ist ja hier eher noch was Neues gewesen, dass es da eher.
Vor allem ja, dass es bei denen gängiger und weil da geht's jetzt eben dem Maler drum, sich Leute an den äh sich Leute zu zu schnappen.
Die unter die möglichst die Höheren ans Messer liefern, ja? Und.
Und er ist schon relativ hoch eingestiegen, ne? Also unter anderem ist ja dieser Michael Flinn. Da äh schon äh bei ihm eingezogen. Immerhin für ein paar Tage äh Sicherheitsberater äh des äh Präsidenten. Also es geht jetzt hier nicht um irgendwelche Leute, sondern es geht um,
Mitarbeiter
die ganz konkret zum Umfeld gehören und man hört halt auch immer wieder, dass mittlerweile in alle Richtungen ermittelt wird, einschließlich der Familie des Präsidenten. Und natürlich wird auch,
Trump selber hinterher investigertiert, aber,
Das ist noch nicht auf dem Tisch, ja? Also man merkt, es baut sich da langsam was auf und äh man wartet eigentlich nur auf den Tag, wo mal der dicke Trump dann selber dran ist.
Man hofft na ja.
Aber erstmal die anderen.
Genau, jetzt hat er ein Stück äh rausgelassen und zwar eine Anklage erhoben gegen russische Trolls oder Trolle? Wie nennt man das.
Menschen heißt das erstmal.
Gegen ja,
Hauptrolle spielt äh ein Freund von Vladimir Putin. Dessen Name lautet Yeveni, Victorovic,
und er fungiert unter dem Spitznamen Putins Koch,
weil er irgendwie ein Catering-Unternehmen hat, was in der Regel für Putin
Veranstaltung und so auftritt, ja? Und der soll dieser gute hin, soll über diverse Firmen und Konten
das Geld für ein Informationskrieg gegen die USA bereitgestellt haben. Insgesamt eins Komma zwei fünf Millionen Dollar monatlich ähm,
hat er ausgegeben und das Kernherzstück war eine sogenannte Trollfabrik in Sankt Petersburg
wo von dreizehn weiteren Beschuldigten mehrere Firmen betrieben wurden, die sich offiziell irgendwie als äh Softwareschmiede, Internetagentur oder Social Media Beratung oder irgendwas ausgegeben haben.
Aber in Wirklichkeit gezielte politische Kampagnen, im Internet betrieben zum Beispiel,
den sozialen Netzwerken wie Instagram, YouTube oder sonstigen.
Und äh insgesamt soll es sich um mehrere hundert Mitarbeiter gehandelt haben, die mit einer eigenen Grafikabteilung, eigenem Surch Engine Optimization Team,
Ähm Datenanalyseteam äh,
in Schichten gearbeitet haben, um den mit dem Zeitunterschied klarzukommen, weil ja unterschiedliche Zeitzonen zwischen den USA und äh Russland kippt. Und äh diese,
haben dann also irgendwann sind irgendwann aggressiver geworden, haben Identitäten von US-Bürgern geklaut, haben äh dann mit deren Sozialversicherungsnummern Konten eröffnet, Anti-Clinton-Werbung bei Facebook als,
US-Amerikaner gekauft äh und äh sind da also sehr ausführlich vorgegangen in den sozialen Netzwerken.
Das ist jetzt erstmal.
Interessant, weil es eben all die die russische oder anscheinend russische Desinformationskampagne aufdeckt.
Und es ist natürlich schon krass, dass da offenbar mit so viel Geld und so viel ähm.
Elaboration und Finess vorgegangen wurde. Und jetzt wird sich hier die Strategie,
immer mehr zeigen, ja? Dass sie also ähm ob sie jetzt.
Klar gegen Clinton und für Trump gearbeitet haben oder ob ihr primär Ziel eine Destabilisierung der Verhältnisse war. Ähm ist jetzt erstmal.
Egal, es ist auf jeden Fall für uns als äh Social Media Opfer und Bürger ähm wichtig zur Kenntnis zu nehmen, dass es da solche Operationen solchen Ausmaßes gibt.
Und ähm es gibt sich nicht ergibt sich daraus natürlich dann noch eine sehr viel längere andere Diskussion. Ob das jetzt aus,
Ob das jetzt so besonders selten ist oder so besonders.
Übel, also so besonders einzigartig oder Cinestar, ja, dass man sagen würde, dass äh die USA so etwas nicht tun. Äh USA hat ja haben ja auch das, was man zumindest zur Kenntnis nehmen. Eine lange Geschichte,
Vom Einmischen in die demokratischen Prozesse anderer Länder.
Auch nicht erst seitdem es das Internet gibt.
Nicht erst seitdem es das Internet gibt, das haben die auch früher schon mit klassischen äh geheimdienstlichen Diffamierungsmethoden oder auch mal mit Waffengewalt und Unterstützung.
Unfallschmeldungen und Flugblättern und sowas. Also Desinformationskampagnen sind nichts Neues, sondern das ist so alt wie der Krieg und das ähm man jetzt sozusagen,
Werkzeuge auf einmal hat um Ladschall auch die Beeinflussung nicht nur auf irgendwelche kleinen entscheidenden Gruppen zu machen, sondern eben auch auf größere Volksschichten und damit eben äh potentiell auch den Ausgang kompletter Wahlen
beeinflussen kann. Das ist das, was jetzt sozusagen als neue Qualität dazu kommt. In diesen Zeiten.
Die ähm die Schlinge um den Hals der sozialen Netzwerke wird auch immer enger. Ja, das, also deren Rolle darin äh gerät zunehmend in äh den Fokus zurecht ähm.
Heute übrigens mit der schönen Meldung, dass Trump äh sogar weniger für seine Anzeigen erzahlen müssen, als Tinten.
Ja ja haben wir drin, wir machen nur äh eine eine langsame Herleitung.
Entschuldigung, ich wollte dir nicht deinen äh deinen Flow brechen hier.
Also erstmal sehr schön zu beobachten war. Ähm.
Am zweiundzwanzigsten Februar äh hatte Twitter dann nochmal mehr sortiert und bessere Kriterien angelegt. Zur Erkennung dessen, was Fake Accounts und Social Bots sind. Und äh hat dann mal äh ein bisschen.
Dadurch gewühlt und aufgeräumt und diese ganzen Accounts gesperrt.
Was dazu führte, dass einige einige ähm sage ich mal so,
Informationskrieger, einige berufene Amerikaner sich beschwerten,
ihnen gerade, dass sie gerade unter voll unerklärlichem Followerverlust äh,
und das ihnen so und so viel tausend Follower geklaut wurden und jetzt hier Twitter zensiert und beschneidet sie in ihrer Meinung, oder? Und das äh das das linke Stabisment geht hier wieder zur Sache und es war sehr amüsant
denen dabei zuzuschauen, weil die offenbar Nachrichten nicht gelesen hatten, weil die in ihrer Filterbubble nicht kamen, dass man jetzt, wenn man gerade mal ein paar tausend Follower verliert
lieber die Fresse hält und so tut, als wäre nix gewesen, ja? Aber ähm.
Lehrgas, also sehr schöne, sehr schöne äh Aufreger und man konnte sich dann zwischenzeitlich darüber Schrott lachen, dass sie sich dann auch die Blöße gegeben haben, dass sie hier betroffen waren. Und.
Aber ich habe für meine Follower so viel bezahlt.
Dafür bezahlt. Ja. Also da kommt, wird ein bisschen drin aufgeräumt. Ähm.
Jetzt hast du es gerade schon vorweggenommen, deswegen nehmen wir das Thema mal auf. Ich habe ja seit Längerem,
gegenüber dieser gesamten Trollgeschichte eine.
Vorsichtige Zurückhaltung ausgeübt äh um nicht zu sagen, dieses Theater, was da drum veranstaltet wird, schon länger kritisiert. Ähm da ich.
Media Male Theater.
Das mediale Theater, äh da ich die die Wurzel des Übels nicht darin sehe, dass irgendwelche Trolls äh oder Bots oder Sonstiges dort äh.
Aktiv sind.
Sondern darin, dass ihr ein Desinformationskampagnen äh ein Nährboden geliefert wird durch.
Quasi durch den Kern dessen wie soziale Netzwerke funktionieren. Und das ist sie deswegen interessant macht für koordinierte Kampagnen äh von,
Prollen und ähm das äh diese äh,
Dieses Modell der zielgruppengerichteten Werbung, das eigentliche Übel ist, ja, dass nämlich hier diese Unternehmen all dieses Wissen über ihre Nutzer sammeln,
und zahlenden Kunden zur Verfügung stellen. Na ja also bei Facebook aktiv ist, kann ja seine dortigen Veröffentlichung,
promoten, damit diese auch den Followern angezeigt werden, das heißt, hier wird die Interaktion mit dem eigenen Publikum,
monetarisiert und äh es ist sehr interessant wie fein auflösend man sich dort eine Zielgruppe bestimmen kann,
Ja, ich stelle das ja immer wieder fest, dass äh auf unserer automatisch gefüllten und unter größten Schmerzen eingerichteten Lokbuchnetzpolitik, Facebookseite, ähm,
irgendwie ein Bruchteil der Follower nur erreicht wird und mir immer wieder angegeben angeregt wird, ich möge doch noch einen weiteren Dollar einwerfen, dann könnte ich das Publikum auch erreichen.
Bitte werfen sie eine Münze.
Genau und wenn du dann sagst, ja, dann kannst du sehr spezifisch gezielt äh aussuchen.
An wen du dich richtest. Und jetzt ist ein sehr interessanter Punkt dabei.
Es stellt sich ja jetzt die Frage, wonach sucht Facebook denn aus? Wie vielen Leuten meine Nachricht angezeigt.
Die haben offenbar irgendeine Form von Algorithmus. Und dieser Algorithmus scheint auch zu funktionieren. Denn wenn auf unserer Facebookseite eine neue Folge Lokbuch Netzpolitik angekündigt wird, dann erreicht,
diese Ankündigung sehr viel mehr Leute,
als wenn einfach nur von unserer Leseliste beispielsweise ein Netzpolitik Ork oder Heise oder sonstige Artikel,
gepostet wird. Ähm die erkennen also offenbar einen Unterschied in der Relevanz. Ich vermute so jetzt mal vorsichtig, ich kenne den Algorithmus ja nicht, weil die erkennen offenbar, dass dieser heiße Artikel von mehreren Leuten eh schon geteilt wurde und deswegen,
nicht so brennend interessant ist wie,
Unsere Folgen, ja? Die von uns als allererstes automatisiert wenige Sekunden nach Veröffentlichung.
Weil's neu ist unter Umstä.
Weil's neu ist.
Leicht konntet es den wir regelmäßig rausbringen, was auch immer.
Und weil's vielleicht auch die Leute, die äh unsere Seite da abonniert haben, vielleicht mehr interessiert, so. Also dann gehen die Zahlen hoch. Ähm.
Ähm sprich, wenn du sowieso interessantes und äh Unique Material hast, musst du eh nicht kaufen.
Richtig. Oder du hast es dann einfacher.
Deine Zielgruppe zu definieren. Und da gibt's jetzt einen sehr spannenden Artikel von oh der Name war schwierig auszusprechen,
Antonio Garcia Martinez, doch war gar nicht so schwer, der früher bei Facebook äh gearbeitet hat und der berichtet jetzt in einem Artikel auf Why-Art,
dass Trump weniger für Facebook-Werbung bezahlt hat als Clinton, weil.
Ja, eine hetzerische Kampagne hatte.
Und diese Hetzerei auf Facebook, auf besseren und fruchtbareren Boden fällt. Das heißt, der hat den größeren Teil eh schon,
An Followern durch Relevanz, durch durch Hetze, durch Vereinfachung, durch Zuspitzung, durch Engagement
gekriegt und musste dann nur noch wenig zahlen, um sich den Rest dazu zu kaufen.
Hetzer-Rabatt.
Hetzer Rabatt.
Ähm die Marie Bröckling, die bei Netzpolitik Org jetzt gerade angefangen hat, als Praktikantin zu schreiben, findet auch den schönen Till dazu. Hetze zum Discounterpreis. Ja,
Ja, also guter Kunde, ja? Der erreicht unser Ziel ja auch so, ähm der hält und der bringt,
Leserinnen und Leser, ähnliches Dilemma wie wie Twitter und er sagt also mit provokativen Sprüchen konnte Trumps Wahlkampagne bares Geld sparen.
Er bekam mehr Medien für weniger Geld. Und äh das finde ich echt äh spannend,
denn der Preis für Werbeanzeigen auf Facebook ist nicht fix, sondern wird mittels Auktion versteigert und es gewinnt nicht der oder die meistbietende, sondern die Werbeanzeige, die voraussichtlich viele Klicks bekommt
Also auch hier haben wir wieder einen inneren Rentenmechanismus, der uns in Richtung der Zuspitzung,
in Richtung der Provokation,
Und damit auch in Richtung einer Vereinfachung und einer Spaltung führt, ja? Je plumper du den Sachverhalt darstellst,
desto relevanter ist das, desto mehr Reichweite kriegst du quasi kostenlos. Ist jetzt auch nichts Überraschendes, ja, dass ähm.
Äh ist klar, dass eben die die Aufmerksamkeit von uns Menschen eher dahin geht, wo es irgendwie krasser ist, ja? Ähm,
Aber es ist natürlich sehr.
Es hat sehr fatale Folgen für die Kommunikation zwischen uns Menschen und die Spaltung in gesellschaftliche Gruppen,
und ähm die werden jetzt endlich immer mehr auseinandergenommen, auch wenn, sage ich mal, bin ich ja nicht der einzige, der da
seit längerer Zeit drauf hinweist, wie gesagt, ich hab das damals schon als diese Anhörung zur Social Bots war ich immer wieder gesagt das Problem
sind nicht die Social Bots. Das Problem sind die inherenden Mechanismen der sozialen Netzwerke. Es gibt da auch renommierte Forscher und Forscherinnen zu
die diese Mechanismen seit Jahren erforschen, belegen und dokumentieren, können uns jetzt können also hoffen.
Dass es in irgendeiner Form mal langsam irgendwann ähm an die.
Mitte der Öffentlichkeit unter den Fokus auch der politischen Regulation kommt, dass das Problem Social Media als Geschäftsmodell heißt,
und dass diese Zielgruppenorientierung das Erstellen von Trends ähm,
Das Problem ist, was übrigens auch gerade dieser äh Schüler erfährt, der ähm.
An der Highschool in Florida war.
An der jetzt mal wieder äh ein Schüler weiß ich nicht. Zweistellige Anzahl Menschen, ich glaub siebzehn,
siebzehn Menschen mit einem Sturmgewehr getötet hat. Und äh was ja jetzt gerade in den USA stattfindet, ist äh dass sich an diesem
die Gesellschaft gerade an diesem Thema spaltet, äh also dem Second Amentment äh The Right to bey arms, also dem.
In den neunzehnhundertsechziger Jahren radikal ausformulierten Grundrecht auf Bewaffnung,
Dazu übrigens 'ne großartige Podcastfolge empfohlen von More Perfect, die müssen wir auch noch hier rein tun. Äh in der der historische Kontext dieser äh radikalisierung des Second Emantment behandelt wurde,
Da wagen sich also jetzt diese Highschool-Schüler, die den Tod von siebzehn Mitschülern und Mitschülerinnen äh beklagen,
Dieses Grundrecht anzugehen, das kann natürlich kannst du nicht auf dir sitzen lassen und entsprechend werden jetzt so Diffamierungsvideos
veröffentlicht auf YouTube und dieser Schüler findet sich irgendwie in einer ähnlichen Verschwörungstheoriesituation wie,
Richard Gut, ja. Dessen Fall wir ja hier auch schon öfter ähm reflektiert haben,
Dass also koordiniert mit solchen Trollgruppen, Diffamierungsvideos,
gepostet wurden und die darauf hinarbeiten, den Algorithmus auszutricksen. Und dieses Video in dem dieser junge Mensch, der irgendwie siebzehn oder achtzehn Jahre alt ist, ähm.
Diffamiert wird, kam also ohne weitere Probleme in diese YouTube Trends. Ja und da ist natürlich jetzt.
Platz eins, ja? Das heißt YouTube gibt dir dann irgendwann die Reichweite wenn du diese Algorithmen austrägst.
Und diese Prozesse in in Bewegung zu bringen ist das, was eben diese ja.
Diesen dunklen, unheimlichen Vorteil für koordinierte.
Ja, Hetzer und in der Regel desinformierer gibt,
und ich sage in der Regel der ist Informierer, weil natürlich auch ab und zu mal ein YouTube-Video zum Trend wird das durchaus den die
das Interesse der Öffentlichkeit verdient. Zum Beispiel habe ich heute ein Video gesehen, wo ein Mann in Asien dem Hund,
'ne Regenjacke und 'n Hut aufzieht, weil's regnet und erst dann sich selber und dann fährt er mit ihm mit dem Fahrrad los und es ist sehr gut, äh, dass
dieses Video zum Trend wurde und in Deutschland gesehen werden konnte, weil es war wichtig
ja? Aber ist halt schlecht wenn es und vor allem war es war, es war geschehen, ja? Dieses Video war nicht zur Diskreditierung, ähm irgendwelcher Menschengruppen,
gedacht und
das was da jetzt passiert, was dieser Schüler eben an seinem Leben äh am, am, an seinem, am eigenen Leibe erfährt, äh ist äh eben jetzt nicht mehr sehr schön, weil's ja eben alle möglichen Verschwörungstheorien, um ihn kippt,
die jetzt koordiniert in dieses in diesem, in diese sozialen Netzwerken verbrei.
Kennst aber auch seine Reaktionen. Ich meine, diese diese äh überlebenden Schüler, die jetzt äh zu Aktivisten werden, sie selber nicht eine bemerkenswerte Truppe,
Er hat sich ja bedankt bei den ganzen Conspiracy, Series dafür, dass er so viel Exporta bekommen hat, sonst wäre er seine Geschichte ja gar nicht so sehr äh,
äh bekannt geworden. Diese gehen dann mit einer interessanten Coolness ran, finde ich, so, diese junge Generation.
Ja, die haben aber auch also die haben ja auch tatsächlich noch ein ganz anderes Problem gerade, sodass ich glaube, wenn du diese, wenn du etwas so Krasses,
In deinem Leben hat es, dann ist dir wahrscheinlich gemessen daran, relativ egal, dass eben ein paar Hitzer da im Internet äh rumrennen, ne?
Langfristig mag sich das auch noch ändern. Ähm so oder so sind die jetzt ohnehin schon Center Stage äh
Trotz alledem zeigen sie auch eine bemerkenswerte Art und Weise, wie man mit diesem medialen Follow umgehen kann, ja? Also was ja ein großes Problem ist und man sieht das ja auch so an Trump
Tweets et cetera und generell diese Auseinandersetzung. Es geht da halt auch so um so ein Agendasetting
durch Ablenkung und durch äh ne, also man man nimmt eigentlich das das eigentliche Thema sozusagen aus der Schusslinie, indem man mit was komplett an einem
ablenkt und das ist eigentlich vollkommen egal, ob es Todli, äh Clulis ist oder also die die Wahrheit spielt an der Stelle keine Rolle mehr, es geht da gar nicht,
primär um die Ablenkung und darum irgendwie ein ganz anderes Thema aufzumachen
uns bemerkenswert, grad für Foxräder, gerade etwas intensiver, wie so diese Gruppe von Schülern, das einfach irgendwie auch auf so eine
moderne, lockere äh Jugendliche Art einfach abfedert,
ja? Die sich eigentlich äh nur lustig darüber macht und dann schon wieder äh dabei ist, die eigene äh Agenda, die ja ganz klar für stärkere Waffengesetze in den USA eintritt
die voranzubringen ähm und sie sind jetzt schon weitergekommen als alle anderen,
Vor ihnen noch ist nichts final erreicht, aber es ist das erste Mal seit zehn zwanzig Jahren, dass nach so einem Maßshooting tatsächlich die öffentliche Meinung
anfängt zu kippen.
Ja, also man kann das nur hoffen, dieses dieses Problem der zivilen Bewaffnung in den USA ist also wirklich absurd und irrsinnig,
Ähm treibt immer neuere Blüten und es ist natürlich sehr, sehr,
Also die Argumentationen sind eben sehr, sehr, sehr skurril, ja? Das hat jetzt also, dass das noch für Blüten getrieben hat, ne. Jetzt sagt der Trump, der ja immer für eine kluge Lösung zu haben ist, hat er jetzt gesagt, also jetzt ganz klar,
Wenn wir so viele School-Shootings haben, dann müssen wir die Lehrer bewaffnen. Zwanzig bis vierzig Prozent der Lehrer als Waffenträger. Es ist.
Das ist so skurril, ja? Also stell dir mal vor, ich meine, was du als Schüler ohnehin unter Lehrern über deine Laufbahn von sagen wir mal zehn bis zwölf bis fünfzehn, Jahren, die du in der Schule verbringst. Ähm,
Zu leiden hast, ja? Und jetzt ist auch noch jeder fünfte von denen bewaffnet, ja. Vor ein paar Jahrzehnten ist grob geschafft, die Prügelstrafe aus dieser Schule rauszuholen, ja? Und jetzt sollen die da wieder die Shares mit der Wumme rumrennen oder was, ne? Also das ist ja, das ist ja alles sowas von.
Also erstens würde es bei diesem Vorfall nicht helfen, äh wenn oder wenn da einer mit einem automatischen Maschinengewehr äh reinmarschiert, dann springen die als erste hinter den Tisch
zweitens ist dann einfach die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass eben diese Waffe entweder entwendet wird oder einer von diesen Lehrern vielleicht selber mal durchdreht oder also ihr einfach auch nur als Drohszenario verwendet
ist dann schon wieder die nächste Eskalationsstufe. Man hat ja schon jetzt auch gesehen, jetzt in Florida. Da waren dann sogar bewaffnete bewaffnete Einsatzkräfte anwesend, die dann sich noch nicht mal reingetraut haben.
Ja, da hatte Trump ja auch schon sein Urteil zugegeben, ne.
Ja, er wäre ja sozusagen auch ohne Waffe reingegangen.
Na er hat erstmal den also diesen ich kann das jetzt auch nicht beurteilen. Ich meine es ist sicherlich relevant, dass dieser äh Schutz,
Beamte da äh ähm.
Suspendiert wurde, dass den Job natürlich los, also wenn dein Job ist eine Schule zu bewachen und du,
und ist da drin halt ein Shooting gibt und du gehst da nicht rein, dann warst du für den Job nicht geeignet, das war die Job so, aber äh.
Donald Trump hat ja groß getönt, er wäre reingegangen, auch ohne Knarre und man denkt sich dann so.
Wärst du mal reingegangen? Und ist ja gar nicht so weit weg von äh von dieser Schule. Also nä.
Man kann nächstes Mal schnell mal hinfliegen.
Nächstes Mal können wir den da schnell hinfliegen und sagen, geh mal schnell rein.
Breen out the Trump.
Ja oh Mann,
Also äh ja, wenn sie da in diesem Fall auch wieder eine eine völlig skurrile Diskussion und man kann da auch,
In den in den USA sowieso, ich meine eine Desinformationskampagne in den USA ist sowieso echt skurril
weil die ja sowieso in ihrem Wahlkampf schon mit so viel Desinformation und bösartigen Unterstellungen ähm arbeiten und zwar schon seit Jahrzehnten
Ja, also das ist bei denen fällt das auch nicht so auf, diese Personen konzentrierten äh Wahlkämpfe, also das irgendwie.
Im Fernsehen so Diffamierungsnachrichten über den politischen Gegner laufen, die sich in der Regel darum um das Thema Abtreibung oder um das Thema Waffen äh Besitz äh.
Drehen, das ist in den USA seit mindestens zwanzig Jahren so.
Und allein das wäre in Deutschland schon eben wie undenkbar, was für skurrilen Scheiß die irgendwie da.
Also es geht natürlich auch einher, muss man sagen mit dem äh mit der Gründung von Fox News,
ist definitiv das Ereignis, was äh den Diskurs in Amerika
komplett gedreht hat und zu dieser Verrohung einfach aktiv dazu beigetragen hat, da ist er das Internet eigentlich nur noch das Sahnehäubchen obendrauf, weil diese permanente Beballerung
von Fox Nuss mit einfach
Macht dann auch ein bisschen fassungslos, ja? Wie schamlos die äh äh da den ganzen Tag irgendwie Agenda-Setting betreiben und eigentlich überhaupt so Nachrichten selber überhaupt gar nicht mehr so richtig transportieren
und wirklich nur unter allerhöchstem Druck, wenn's wirklich sich alles überhaupt nichts mehr zu leugnen lässt. Äh vielleicht dann doch nochmal kurz so ein bisschen so ein Realitätseinschub haben
Ja, ich hoffe, dass wir dem noch lange äh fern bleiben äh können, da hilft unter anderem übrigens auch öffentliche Rundfunk, äh, mal so ganz nebenbei jetzt, wo irgendwie die.
Schweizhitze sowas auch noch abschaffen will, also in Österreich. Na ja, egal, ich will jetzt hier auch das Thema nicht zu weit ähm.
Rausschieben. Also Social Media ist ein Problem, schreit so ein bisschen nach Regulierung, die Frage ist nur, wo reguliert man's hin? Ähm.
Oder kriegen wir kriegen wir die Kurve, dass Menschen damit ein.
Dass Menschen sich an das Medium gewöhnen, ja damit einen anderen Umgang pflegen, Treuekommentare, schneller erkennen oder so, auch das wäre ja denkbar, wir haben uns ja ein viel ungemach gewöhnt,
Ähm aktuell sind wir da auf jeden Fall noch in so einer Findungsphase.
Ja und da stellt sich natürlich auch die Frage, inwiefern äh haben wir ja hier auch schon oft getan
Inwiefern ist sagen wir mal der Algorithmus hier dann auch im Mittelpunkt des Ganzen, weil die Algorithmen, die hier zum, also nicht so diese Forderung mit, na ja, äh
Dieses und jenes soll rausgefiltert werden. Das ist ja schon mal die Frage, ne, vielleicht, dass da das eine rausfällt, dass was anderes nicht raus, wer bestimmt das, was das ist, was bedeutet das eigentlich genau,
wie kann man denn eigentlich überprüfen, ob das auch tatsächlich funktioniert, weil alles das, was herausgefiltert wurde, das ist ja dann auch schon weg
gibt's da überhaupt eine Accountability? Gibt's irgendwie einen einen Beleg mit was alles rausgefiltert wurde? Kann man das irgendwo nachlesen? Wer schreibt dieser,
Algorithmen wird garantiert dafür, dass dieser Algorithmen überhaupt funktionieren. Wer garantiert vor allem dafür, dass sie nicht auf dem Weg äh dahin irgendwas äh angeblich verboten ist, rauszufiltern, noch sehr viel mehr erlaubt ist äh auf der Strecke geblieben ist.
Also wir haben, was wir aber auch hier in Lockwohnheimspolitik schon ausführlich kritisiert haben, ist, warum überhaupt äh äh also Facebook.
Was erlaube? Ähm irgendwie, dass man quasi Informationen von den Leuten fernhält, die gesagt haben, ich möchte sie haben,
ja? Also das ist und wenn sie das nicht tun würden, hätten sie eben auch kein Geschäftsmodell. Und genau weil also,
Ja, ich kriege zu viel. Es ist einfach alles so verkehrt, dass man das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr fixen kann. Okay, aber wir haben gesagt, Schuld sind.
Die sozialen Netzwerke, denn sie bieten insbesondere mit ihren Empfehlungen, mit ihren Trends, mit dem wir glauben, wir sortieren mal das für dich weg
weil das interessiert dich wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr, sondern wir geben dir dafür das hier, das könnte dich mehr interessieren und oder das hat jemand bezahlt, das was dir trotzdem anzeigen ähm und damit optimieren wir
Zeit, die du auf dieser Seite bleibst, dass sie mit dieser Herangehensweise,
Zu einem gesellschaftlichen Problem geworden sind, weil man das spielen kann und weil es zu verkürzter äh provokativer, pronunzierter,
Auseinandersetzung führt, weil man sich da äh die Aufmerksamkeit kauft und weil das gerade wirklich katastrophale politische ähm
Konsequenzen hat nicht nur
den politischen kurzfristigen Ergebnissen, die wir bis jetzt schon sehen, sondern vor allem auch, dass wir Menschengruppen voneinander entfernen gegeneinander aufhetzen und ihnen die Kommunikation und das Verständnis vollkommen unmöglich machen.
So sieht's aus.
Wäre aber traurig, wenn es sowas nicht auch in Deutschland,
geben würde. Ähm, Artikel, der schon vor mehreren Wochen von Markus Reuter bei Netzwerk Ork veröffentlicht wurde, wo es sich eine solch solche Treue,
Gruppierung, eine rechtsradikale Treugrupierung.
Entschuldigung, der Artikel ist nicht nur von Markus Reuter, sondern von Markus Reuter und Anabis Elli haben's zusammengemacht. Ähm die sich dort militärisch äh,
organisieren, beziehungsweise ihre Hierarchien in militärischen Begriffen äh widerspiegeln und sich in einem.
Cord-Forum irgendwie äh immer wieder abgesprochen haben. Sowas, irgendwie, ja, der der Gefreite, ist der Anfänger in diesem Forum und da muss dann irgendwie ein Gewerbesprich absolvieren und dann wird da irgendwann,
General und dann wird halt eben wie gesagt Achtung Achtung,
Wir geben bekannt, äh wir werden in Kürze ein Video fertig haben, wir werden das am Sonntag, achtzehnten Februar veröffentlichen, Gefreite erhalten von nun an einen Tag ähm,
Und die müssen das veröffentlichen ähm schließt euch äh dem Nachschub an, also der Nachschub sind wahrscheinlich irgendwie die die dann äh.
Für die Verbreitung sorgen wir es woanders noch hochladen, um das Netz damit zu fluten. Die ist also irgendwie äh koordinieren.
Auch sehr hm sehr interessant, äh dass es solche.
Solche Leute gibt, ja, die es hier in dem Fall wahrscheinlich nicht mit einem russischen Millionenbudget machen, sondern aus äh Überzeugung und natürlich in diesem Fall.
Für die AfD.
Ja, ich meine, ist ja auch eh so ein Effekt, dass einfach Leute, die
in so 'ner Antistimmung sind, um nicht gleich zu sagen, auch in so einer Hassstimmung sind, die sich schon so sehr von,
unserer letzten und dem, dem Thema Hilfs des letzten Kapitels hier haben aufheizen lassen, dass sie dann in dieser Blase auch sind und das dann auch einfach,
Ich mein ich würde sogar nicht mal Alten unterstellen, dass sie wissen was sie tun, ne? Die sind einfach so aufgeheizt durch Falschinformationen,
und so ein ja der Beschuldigung unschuldiger, ja? Hier diese
Diese Minderheit ist äh für alles verantwortlich, was was dir nicht gefällt, ja? Wir lassen dich das jetzt äh glauben. Stattdessen sollst du Leute wählen,
die zwar überhaupt nichts unternehmen, was in deinem Interesse ist, aber wir reden dir das jetzt einfach mal ein und dann sind die irgendwie in so einem Verteidigungsmodus, dass sie das Gefühl sind, sie müssen jetzt hier irgendwie
Diesen Start vor dem Untergang retten. Ich meine, das ist so ein Gefühl, was man bei diesem Pegida-Demonstrationen auch bekommt. Diese hysterischen Leute.
Teilweise, teilweise tatsächlich glauben irgendwie der Untergang naht,
Also das ist so Endzeit äh Stimmung plus Plus teilweise und sich dadurch halt auch so in so einem Modus sehen, dass jetzt quasi wie eine Armee,
ja? Hier in den Krieg ziehen müssen, um den bösen Feind,
zu vernichten, um alles zu retten, so mal ganz übertrieben äh dargestellt. Und dann ist das natürlich auch kein Wunder, dass sie sich dann eben auch online genau in solchen überladenen Gruppen zusammenstellen. Das macht's natürlich nicht besser, was die da sagen. Ich versuche ja nur so ein bisschen so nachzuvollziehen, wie die Motivation ist, weil wir natürlich, die wir jetzt so sagen, etwas
Ähm wie soll ich sagen, ausgewogeneren
Blick auf den Lauf der Dinge haben und auch irgendwie gelernt haben, dass es so mit dem schwarzen, dem weißen, dem Gut und dem Böse auch alles gar nicht so einfach ist. Und das im Zeitfall alle irgendwie so ein bisschen Dreck am Stecken hat, aber dass man am Ende auch mit so einer Gesellschaft am besten fährt, wenn man halt einfach permanent
für Ausgleich und Kompromisse sucht, auch wenn sie schwierig sind, aber dass man dann am Ende eigentlich für alle zumindest irgendwelche Fortschritte hat und dass es dann auch
zu einer erträglichen und stabilen Gesellschaft führen kann, dass wir uns halt nicht in dem selben Maße äh aufgewiegelt sehen, jetzt diesen Einflüssen, die wir teilweise eben auch gar nicht so
unmittelbar wahrnehmen.
Äh sofort was entgegenzusetzen, wie hier mit viel Wissen und Einblicken und Lesen und verfolgen von News, et cetera und im Hören von Podcasts bekommt man diesen diesen Eindruck und sieht auf einmal
etwas, was so erstmal nicht unbedingt sichtbar ist,
Weil die laufen ja nicht alle unbedingt auf der Straße rum, ja? So Nazi-Demo und so weiter, das merkt man irgendwie sofort. Das ist natürlich extrem unangenehm, da muss auch was äh dagegen getan werden. Aber diese ganzen Aktivitäten, die halt im Netz äh stattfinden und nur so ein zweiter, ein dritter Ordnung. Äh letzten Endes äh Einflüsse auf das, was man wahrnimmt haben
die sind natürlich sehr schwer zu äh finden.
Ich habe,
mich mit äh Konstanze äh unterhalten. Die hat irgendwie durch Zufall ist sie nochmal auf die erste Folge Lokbuch Netzpolitik aufmerksam geworden. Die erste, ja.
Die erste. Die erste. Von allen.
Die aller allererste von allen.
Originalsendung.
Den den Grund allen übelst, ja? Und ähm da haben wir, da haben wir schon darüber gesprochen, dass es in diesem Internet ähm.
Im Prinzip immer ein Vorteil für jene gibt, die die kürzere Story erzählen
weil's auch keine besondere besondere Weisheit in diesem Satz, ja? Das haben wir auch vorher schon mit mit der Bildzeitung gesehen äh und sonstigen. Das Problem ist natürlich,
ähm wirklich ein gesellschaftliches, wenn eine Auseinandersetzung immer beliebig,
Komplex werden kann und komplexer werden kann und es eben eine gewisse Tiefe der Auseinandersetzung mit dem Sachverhalt erfordert.
Da zu einem Urteil zu kommen. Und wir haben,
Jede einzelne Person eine eingeschränkte Bandbreite, wie viel wir verarbeiten können und ähm Menschen, die Sorgen haben, haben unter Umständen noch sehr viel eingeschränkter Bandbreite, ja, die müssen sich auch um äh Dinge kümmern
irgendwelche unschönen Arbeiten äh erledigen oder unschöne Arbeiten suchen. Und die haben unter Umständen gesellschaftliche,
Probleme sehr, sehr viel näher am eigenen Leib, ja? Spüren die sehr viel mehr, ja? Und die können natürlich dann auch gerne mal äh echt.
Verzweifeln und genau diese Leute werden gerade äh mit einfachen Lösungen gefischt. Das ist so die eine Sache, die ich über Politik gelernt habe,
viel habe ich ja nicht gelernt, aber eine Sache ist es meistens am Ende ein bisschen komplexer. Und jetzt haben wir leider irgendwie eine zunehmende Gruppe von Menschen, die sobald es die jetzt quasi so ein leicht komplexer,
Dann dafür halten, dass das die ähm dass das jetzt die Wahrheit sein muss, weil sie ist ja komplexer,
Und meistens nicht merken, dass das einzige, was da komplex ist, eigentlich eine Verschwörungstheorie.
Na ja, lange genug darüber philosophiert, wir haben also mit diesem Phänomen als Gesellschaft jetzt umzugehen.
Und ich bin gespannt, welche Wege wir da finden werden, die jetzt nicht in irgendwelchen dämlichen Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz, alles löschen, alles weg vom Fenster. Ähm.
Münden, sondern darin, dass man, dass wir irgendwie.
Diese zugrunde liegenden Geschäfts und Kommunikationsmodelle in die Bahn lenken, die uns die den offenen, ernsthaften.
Progressiven politischen Diskurs waren. Denn äh unabhängig davon, ob man jetzt irgendwie die AfD sympathisant ist oder nicht. Äh wird,
festzustellen sein, dass eine gesellschaftliche, diskursive Auseinandersetzung hier nicht mehr stattfindet.
Da profitieren jene, die sich das für unser schönes Land. Und auch unsere schöne äh unseren schönen Start äh wünschen und die davon profitieren.
So, kommen wir zu unseren angeblich kürzeren Themen.
Du hast das nächste Thema schon vorbereitet und wirst zweifeln, ob wir das so schnell hinkriegen. Also.
Ich zweifel immer.
Es gibt ein neues Projekt von Ale Semsrott, Arne Semsrott hier, regelmäßig erwähnt und der war auch glaube ich schon mal zu Gast, oder? Weiß ich noch nicht.
Glaube nicht, nur tausendmal erwähnt.
Na gut, dann müssen wir da mal was dran ändern.
Oder hattest du den irgendwie nochmal separat? Ich glaube nicht. Ich schaue nochmal kurz nach, aber ich glaube nicht.
Ich dachte eher Duett. Also Arne Semsrott, ich hatte ihn ja zuletzt auf jeden Fall nochmal seinen Vortrag äh empfohlen beim Kongress.
Der war noch nicht hier.
Nicht hier, Arne schäme dich ähm.
Warum hast du nicht von uns noch nicht einladen.
Müssen wir mal äh sorry. Also, neues Projekt und zwar Open Schufa. Ähm,
Ziel ist jetzt quasi oder Problemsetzung. Es gibt die Schufa,
Und die Schufa hat nach eigenen Angaben achthundertvierundsechzig Millionen positiv positive und negative Daten über siebenundsechzig einhalb Millionen natürliche Personen und fünf Komma drei Millionen Unternehmen.
Und aus diesem errechnet sie für jede einzelne Identität einen sogenannten Bonitätscore der die Kreditwürdigkeit dieses Unternehmens oder dieser Person.
Beziffern soll. Ähm! Und in diesen Score gehen
Natürlich oder vermutlich so Sachen ein, wie ist diese Person schon vorher äh vertragsbrüchig geworden äh zu in Mitzahlungen in Verzug geraten oder sonstiges, ja?
Aber auch eine Reihe an anderen Dingen, zum Beispiel haben wir hier vor Jahren mal diskutiert, dass die Schufa in einem Pilotprojekt erforschen wollte, ob sie nicht die das Social Media Verhalten zur Prognose zukünftiger,
Kreditwürdigkeit heranziehen könnte und dafür einen größeren äh Shitstorm erreicht hatte.
Ähm das Interessante ist, man kann sich die Daten, die die Schufa hat.
Einmal im Jahr als Bürger im Rahmen einer Selbstauskunft geben lassen,
Sagt man, gib mal her, was hast denn du eigentlich über mich? Interessant, was die alles haben, ja? Das sind dann immer natürlich Informationen, die man,
einem anderen Schufa-Partner gegeben hat und jen ihm gesagt hat, du darfst eine Auskunft bei der Schufe einholen und deine Erfahrungen mit mir mit der Schufa teilen.
Jetzt möchte der ähm.
Und viele andere Menschen, aber ganz gerne wissen, was berechnen die denn, denn wenn welche Information und in welcher Form eine Information an die Schufa geht und wie sie dort gewertet wird, bleibt uns verborgen.
Die Schufa sagt dann einfach Score. Ja? Und davon hängt unter Umständen eben ab. Kriegst du einen Kredit zum,
Kauf eines Hauses, kriegst du einen Mobilfunkvertrag oder, oder, oder.
Und laut einem BGH-Urteil aus dem Jahr zweitausendvierzehn darf die Schuhfahrt diesen Algorithmus,
Diese Berechnungsgrundlage als schützenswertes Betriebsgeheimnis behalten und muss ihn nicht offenlegen.
Aber wie ist das aus dem Sitten von der Schufa selber rausgelesen habe, schon gegenüber dem Staat.
Das kann sein, aber dem Staat weiß ich nicht. Ob ich dem da so traue.
Ich meine, man überprüfen kann man's damit immer noch nicht, aber es ist sozusagen jetzt nicht so ein komplettes Geheimnisgeheimnis, sondern sozusagen nur ein nicht öffentliche Information.
Okay, wichtig, das äh zu sagen. Jetzt geht er ähm jetzt geht der Arme hin und sagt, pass auf holt euch doch mal alle so eine Schufa-Auskunft. Gebt mir die Daten.
Und wenn ich genug habe, dann kann ich prognostizieren, dann kann ich quasi Reverse enginieren, wie dieser Algorithmus funktioniert,
indem ich nämlich alle eure Daten in ein eigenes Datenmodell pflege und versuche die Daten so zu biegen, dass ich den Bonitätscore rauskriege.
Und dann weiß ich, was die, was sie wie bewerten. Und ja, bin ich.
Also da glaube ich, je nachdem wie komplex dieser ähm.
Dieser Algorithmus ist, den die Schufa da anwendet, braucht man dafür eine ganze ganze Menge.
Solcher Datensätze. Und das könnte glaube ich schwierig sein,
Algorithmus wirklich vollständig reverse enginieren zu können und damit das komplette Betriebsgeheimnis der Schufa aus ihren eigenen Daten eins zu eins wiedergeben zu können
Was aber glaube ich durchaus möglich sein wird ist unter Umständen.
Einzelne Diskriminierungs oder Ungleichmäßigkeiten und Unrechtmäßigkeiten in den Ergebnissen dieses Algorithmus,
herauszufinden. Das wiederum wird relativ einfach möglich sein. Und das ist eine äh insofern wiederum eine Forderung, die ich die äußerst wichtig ist und die uns in Zukunft noch sehr, sehr viel mehr beschäftigen wird. Ähm,
wenn,
irgendwelche algorithmischen Entscheidungen getroffen werden, die für von großer Relevanz für uns als Menschen sind, dann brauchen wir deine Transparenz drüber, damit wir das als Gesellschaft kontrollieren können.
Argumentation der Schufa dann wiederum in ihrem Vita-Wort, was ja dann veröffentlicht haben äh
Na ja, aber wenn dieser Algorithmus ja bekannt sei, wie das berechnet wird, dann würde das ja Tür und Tor äh für den Missbrauch öffnen, weil ja dann alle sozusagen ihre Profile entsprechend optimieren könnten, um dann bei der Schufa irgendwie äh trotzdem noch eine gute Bewertung zu erhalten, nehmen sie das eben austricksen,
Fragt man sich natürlich, wie wackelig ist eigentlich euer Algorithmus eigentlich, dass der äh solchen Gefährdung ausgesetzt zu sein scheint.
Es ist natürlich auch noch ein bisschen, also die werden ja äh,
Also die die Antwort der Schufa ist fällt auch auf jeden Fall unter äh getroffene Hunde bellen. Äh da sie ja auch direkt noch versuchen
Kampagne Open Schufa in Misskredit zu bringen, ja? Irgendwie Zweifel an der Unabhängigkeit der Kampagne bleiben, bestehen,
weil sie sich beschweren, dass es, dass sie hier Ziel dieser Kampagne sind und nicht andere Auskunft teilen. Dazu hat Arna aber natürlich relativ einfach erklärt
das ist halt die relevante Auskunft Tai und diese, das ist diejenige, die größte
und die relevanteste und die von der wir natürlich auch am ehesten die Daten bekommen. Die anderen schaffen wir uns danach ran. Wörtlich hat er gegenüber
heiße gesagt, ähm wir,
müssen alle Scoring-Agenturen transparenter aufbauen und transparenter gestalten und das ist natürlich das zugrunde liegende Ziel dieser Kampagne.
Funktioniert folgendermaßen, man fordert über Selbstauskunft dort Nett ähm so eine Auskunft an, die kommt dann nicht so viel später.
Die hatte bei mir echt viele Seiten und dann äh schickt man die möglichst natürlich verschlüsselt an.
Das Projekt Open Schufan.
Mir ist es nicht gelungen mit der Maus eine Unterschrift zu machen.
Wieso? Die prüfen ja eh nicht. Kannst du auch hochladen, glaube ich.
Ne, man muss da irgendwie mit der Maus eine Unterschrift machen und.
Ist kein Apple Pen? Hat die Stufe nicht gereicht oder was.
Bin ja, bin ja nicht so ein Apple-Elitest, wie du.
Naja, musst du, also ich habe das irgendwie hingekriegt und weiß noch nicht mal mehr. Ich habe das, also meine letzte Selbstauskunfts,
offensive ist auch schon etwas länger her. Ich hatte damals hier bei Lokpo Netzwerk auch darüber erzählt.
Ja, also eine auf jeden Fall eine Kampagne, die sich zumindest mal mit einem größeren Problem, das wir seit längerer Zeit in unserer Gesellschaft haben, auseinandersetzt.
Die offenbar auch sofort dazu geführt hat, dass die Schufa sich irgendwie in in großer.
In großen und vielen Worten und mit großem Statement dagegen zur Wehr setzt, auch direkt irgendwie die Unabhängigkeit der Kampagne, also irgendwie die die Unabhängigkeit der Open-Dollage Foundation äh in
in Zweifel stellt, das ist natürlich schon irgendwie,
zeigt, dass sind da offenbar gerade echt die die Muffe geht und ich vermute denen geht nicht die Muffe, weil der, weil es wirklich gelingen wird, den kompletten.
Algorithmus tatsächlich zu Reverse Enginieren, aber ich rechne damit, dass das relativ schnell rauskommt, dass da bestimmte äh strukturierte ähm Benachteiligungen, strukturelle Benachteiligungen, absichtlich oder unabsichtlich entstehen,
und bin sehr gespannt äh was da noch alles bei rauskommen wird.
Wie man so ein Unternehmen mit so einem, so einem Alleinstellungsmerkmal ähm,
muss sich nicht wundern, dass sie äh an der Stelle auch einfach in der Kritik steht.
Kajales sein, dass das alles total super ausgeglichen und Pipapo ist, auch wenn so die die Evidenz der Straße dann nicht unbedingt drauf hinweist,
Ja, aber nehmen wir mal an, das wäre alles so super. Dieses Argument mit, wir können das jetzt nicht transparent machen. Ich finde ja, dass allein schon ein Bewertungsscore.
Der davon lebt, dass man ihn nicht bekannt macht an sich schon mal federhaft ist.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall sehr skurril, ne? Also eigentlich mein mir fällt das auch nicht ein, wie das gehen sollte, weil diese Zustimmung, dass wenn du mit einem Vertragspartner,
Ein Verhältnis eingehst und dass er an die Schuh verliefern darf und dass er von der Schufa erfragen darf, die es ihm überall Grundvoraussetzung, ne? Schufa-Auskunft, wenn du eine Wohnung mieten willst, wenn du
Mietvertrag haben wird. Und insofern kann ich mir auch schwer vorstellen, dieses Ding irgendwie zu gamen
Ja, dass man sagt, ah, ich kenne den Algorithmus und deswegen mache ich jetzt gezielte Sorge, ich für gezielte Einträge in die Schufa-Datenbank.
Um in diesem Algorithmus irgendwie besser voranzukommen oder nicht.
Vielleicht gibt's ja auch irgendwelche Bactors.
Na die würden aber bei einem Reverse Engineering des Algorithmus nicht relevant werden.
Wow, weiß man denn nicht. Also.
Also ich glaube hier, hier gibt's einfach ein Unternehmen, das eine marktbeherrschende Stellung hat,
und das ganz, ganz empfindlich darauf reagiert, dass jemand Interesse für die genaue Ausgestaltung der Geschäftspraktiken hat und so lese ich auch diese.
Dieses Ding, ja? Warnung vor Herausgabe der Schufa-Datenübersicht, die Schufa warnt, Verbraucher regelmäßig davor, die Datenübersicht nach lang einen Dritten weiterzugeben. Ist interessant, ja? Ähm,
denn deren Geschäftsmodell ist anderen die ganze Zeit Datenauskünfte zu geben.
Über andere.
Über andere, ja, aber ihr macht sie bloß nicht selber, macht ich kann dich nur davor warnen, Tim, das sind brisante Informationen, die kann man jederzeit missbräuchlich verwenden.
Ja
Das sind die Daten, die ihr erheb.
City, die wenn man die bei euch kauft, ist es natürlich okay, ne?
Äh da werden wir dafür bezahlt, dann Geld.
Also ich muss sagen, ich bin nicht überzeugt, dass das dieser Algorithmus einer Geheimhaltung bedarf. Ich habe es noch,
Auch in keinem sonstigen Umfeld festgestellt, dass ein Algorithmus einer Geheimhaltung bedarf und äh wäre gespannt für Argumente,
Warum dieser Algorithmus ausgerechnet dieser Algorithmus oder diese Berechnungsgrundlage ausgerechnet einem einer Geheimhaltung bedarf? Deswegen fände ich es super.
Wer das weiß, kann es gerne in den Kommentaren bitte erläutern.
Ja die Schufa könnte das auch mal selber erläutern. Also ich meine.
So wie die gerade aufgescheucht sind, machen die das sogar. Liebe Schufa, kommentiert mal bei uns in den Kommentaren.
Ja, also ich meine wenn das so ist, irgendwie erklärt doch mal warum denn eigentlich, also wer ist wodurch da bedroht.
Handelt sich um ein objektives Verfahren. Ist doch super. Dann gibt's zwar kein Problem.
Podiumens Billow.
Na ja, auch andere müssen sich ja zur Wehr setzen. Ja. Gegen böse, böse, böse Nutzer.
Das ist wirklich eine Story, die äh bekam ich per per E-Mail zugesandt, aufmerksam hören,
Und zwar vertreibt da ein äh kleiner,
Softwareentwickler oder Flugenthusiast einen ein für ein Flugsimulator.
Das ist tatsächlich nicht selten. Also es gibt diese,
Flugsimulatoren oder wahrscheinlich ist das auch der eine Flugsimulator und für den kann man Plugins schreiben. Diese Plugins bestehen hauptsächlich in weiteren Flugzeugen. Ja, das heißt, du hast irgendeine ähm.
Ja, ist der Microsoft Flugs im Rathaus, ja? Du hast den Microsoft Flugsimulator und ähm da sind eigentlich nur relativ wenige Flugzeuge dabei und es gibt eben so einen Sekundärmarkt, in dem Enthusiasten, Flugzeuge entwickeln,
wo dann eben, ne, mit mach ein Foto von dem Cockpit und ähm,
gleichen die Parameter, wie die sich die, wie dieses Flugzeug reagiert und so alles Mögliche an und dann kannst du dir eben bei den Airbus hast du nicht gesehen, noch für deinen Fly-Semialater dazu kaufen. Und.
Das sind äh das Unternehmen um das es hier geht ist die Flight Sim Labs,
Ja und die haben also ein ein für den Microsoft Light Simulator, das den Airbus dreihundertzwanzig,
was er ein sehr häufig äh anzutreffendes Flugzeug ist und äh diese Software verkaufen sie eben für so irgendwie sowas wie achtzig Dollar.
Und wie jeder andere Softwareschmiede aus, auch müssen sie natürlich damit äh leiden sie natürlich darunter, dass ihre Software.
Auch der Piraterie an Heimfeld. Und ähm.
Da hat der Entwickler oder dieses Unternehmen sich jetzt entschieden zu einer sehr interessanten Gegenmaßnahme und zwar, wenn da ein.
Als gestohlen oder mehrfach verwendeter Registrierungscode eingegeben wird, also eine Seriennummer ähm dann klauen sie die im Browser Chrome gespeicherten Passwörter.
Und schieben die an ihren Server. Das machen sie aber nicht.
Wenn du diese Software gekauft hast und sie versuchen.
Damit angeblich Zugänge zu finden, zu irgendwelchen klassischen äh bösartigen Seiten, um,
damit zu finden, wer die da hochgeladen hat. Das ist glaube ich so ihr.
Ja, ihr Grund, womit sie das jetzt behaupten ähm rechtfertigen zu können.
Ich finde das sehr interessant, weil das ist auf jeden Fall ähm.
Nicht legal. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das legal ist. Weil dass du die Passwörter aus dem Passwortshafe deiner Nutzer klaus.
Ja, vor allem mit welcher Intention, ne? Also das heißt ja eigentlich nur, dass sie sozusagen äh bereit sind, dann sozusagen diese Passwörter auch zu nutzen.
Ja und das ist äh.
Oder in Geiselhaft zu nehmen, was auch immer.
Also was sie, was sie damit machen, sie sagen einfach nur, wenn das für ein.
Sie richtet sich gegen spezifische Seriennummern. Also das Ding meldet bei dem Registrierungsprozess, sagt das, meldet das die SEOS,
Seriennummer an diesen Server und wenn das eine Geblacklistete ist, von der das Betreiber davon ausgeht, dass diese für raubkopierte Software verwendet wird, dann,
wird Test Punkt Exe aufgeführt, ausgeführt und ähm.
Und schickt alle Passwörter nach Hause.
Also zumindest in Browsern und Systemen, wo diese auf diese Passwörter ohne weiteres zugegriffen werden kann, was offenbar.
Diese Methode hat bereits erfolgreich Informationen übermittelt, die wir in unserem äh On-Going League ergänzt, Setch Criminals verwenden.
Also ich vermute mal, sie werden dann,
Weil wozu denn sonst? Wenn sie Leute äh rechtlich ausfindig machen wollen, wollen sie ja quasi ihre Identität feststellen
das geht natürlich jetzt mit einem PayPal
oder sonst irgendwie Account ganz wunderbar, weil da logt man sich einmal ein und dann sind dann die äh hinterlegten Informationen ja meistens auch recht rechtsverbindlich, weil man sich ja gerade mit Zahlungsdiensten gegenüber zum Beispiel,
äh dann auch mal ausweisen muss, um überhaupt daran teilnehmen zu können und dann äh schickt man denen halt einen Brief nach Hause.
Also hier.
Das ist echt krass. Das geht so nicht. Aber weil wir im Vorgespräch darüber gesprochen haben und du sagtest, wie das geht, ja das geht,
ähm relativ einfach. Äh in zumindest Firefox und Chrome, die ihre eigen implementierten Passwort Safes haben
wenn diese nicht Passwort geschützt sind, zusätzlich
dann liegt hier die Methode zur Entschlüsselung oder die Information zur Entschlüssung und zum Öffnen und Auslesen des gesamten Passwortsafes quasi frei
Und dann kannst du das machen.
Frei per welchem API, also nicht normal.
Die liegen in einer DB-Datei. Also wir haben das mal vor längerer Zeit im.
Beruflichen Kontext getan, deswegen kann ich da jetzt nicht so viel zu erzählen, aber die liegen in einer Datei und es ist jetzt keine besondere äh Schwierigkeit, äh sich,
den Teil nochmal nachzubauen oder aus einer existenten
Firefox Codebasis abzuschauen, wie also diese Passwörter ausgelesen werden können aus dieser Datei. Wenn man sie nicht zusätzlich mit einem Passwort geschützt hat, war's die meisten
oder was viele Nutzer eben nicht tun.
Und dann ist es schlecht, wenn du ähm Zugriff auf diese Datei bekommst. Und so ein Installa.
Kriegt da eben Zugriff drauf.
Ich vermute mal, dieser Flying Flugsimulator funktioniert ja eh nur in der Bindungszone sozusagen, so ein.
Das ist kann ich nichts zu sagen
Windows hat aber auch eine eigene Passwortspeicher API und es kann auch sein, dass Firefox zum Beispiel die inzwischen verwendet. Auf den neueren Betriebssystemversionen, aber ein, es sollte auch ohne Spezifika der Implementierung einleuchten, dass ein Passwort safe
der nicht mit einem Passwort geschlüsselt ist nicht,
besonders guten Schutz bieten kann, weil er ja offenbar ohne Passwort zuzugreifen ist. Um da keine weitere Zugangssicherung sein kann, die äh nennenswert,
sein könnte. Und das hat sich hier dieser äh dieser Hersteller zunutze gemacht und ähm das natürlich,
Also es, ich meine, das ist unpresident. Unpresidentit, ja.
Und Presidented.
Präsident, das erinnert noch irgendwie, äh ich glaube ähm Sony hat auch mal irgendwann in den neunziger Jahren so einen DVD-Kopierschutz gemacht, wo sie im Prinzip ein Routkit auf den auf den befallenen Systemen.
Hatten wir ja auch ausführlich schon äh besprochen. Das war ähnlich hardcore.
Ja, das geht eben nicht. Sorry. Also ist ärgerlich, wenn dann macht und vor allem ist auch wirklich nicht.
Ja und vor allem man bringt.
Wenn du doch eh deine Lizenzschlüssel prüfst und Lizenzschlüssel online sperren kannst, dann kannst du doch diese Nutzer auch daran hindern, deine Software zu verwenden und dann ist doch auch bitte Frieden im Karton,
muss doch wirklich dann sagen, okay, du hast nicht bezahlt, du kriegst die Leistung nicht, alles klar, wunderbar, dann musst du doch alles in Ordnung sein. Ja, es gibt ja ähm.
Mit jemand eine Nummer geklaut wird und es ist aber gekauft hat, dann kann er sich ja dahinwenden und eine neue kriegen, alles gar.
Der neue, so alles in Ordnung so, das Problem ist gelöst und äh da Hackingangriffe zu fahren, die eben eindeutig, also,
von Daten, äh Stör fallen
in Deutschland und sicherlich auch in äh in den USA unter den Computer fort and the Beause Act. Äh dann äh geht der nicht.
Na ja, Ende vom Lied, nachdem der Artikel rauskam und die Aufregung äh stieg, haben sie diese Softwareversion zurückgezogen, neue Plugin hat das Feature nicht mehr Ende der Geschichte.
Ja, ich hoffe da eigentlich, dass demnächst mal irgendjemand verklagt. Weil er sich ja selber bezichtigt, dass er diese Informationen genommen und verwendet hat äh und dass äh.
Na, ist ja eigentlich ein Fall für eine Staatsanwaltschaft, die jetzt hier einfach nach Faktenlage und Kenntnislage äh eigentlich selber Klage erheben kann. Da muss jetzt nicht unbedingt ein Betroffener machen, aber frisch. Down Asme Award US äh Justices.
Schön, schön ist, dass der Entwickler an seine äh Kunden schreibt. Einige wenige von euch.
Fühlten sich unwohl mit dieser besonderen Methode, die man als ein bisschen äh.
Hemmsärmlich an auf von unserer Seite bezeichnen könnte. Hast du ein sehr äh sehr schöne Formulierungen.
So
So, weiter.
Stellt sich raus, äh es gibt gar keinen Breitbandausbau. Wer hätte das gedacht, Tim, wir wollten ja eigentlich bis zwanzig achtzehn alle.
Niemand hat die Absicht, eine Glasfaser zu verlegen.
Äh da gibt's eine schöne äh also,
Ende zwanzig achtzehn sollten ja, so hat es uns die GroKo versprochen, alle Haushalte über Internetzugänge mit mindestens fünfzig Megabit pro Sekunde verfügen.
Ist nichts draus geworden und jetzt wird's interessant.
Da wurde ja wurden ja jeweils hunderte Millionen für zur Verfügung gestellt. Und zweitausendsechzehn wurden dafür vierhundert Millionen Fördergelder zur Verfügung gestellt und von diesen vierhundert Millionen Euro Fördergeldern wurden fünf,
abgerufen. Und zweitausendsiebzehn wurden sechshundertneunzig Millionen Euro Fördergelder bereitgestellt, abgerufen wurden davon zweiundzwanzig.
Ähm.
Und jetzt stellt sich heraus, dass diese Förderanträge regelmäßig aufgrund der Verfahrenskomplexität zurückgezogen wurden.
Teilweise Ausbauvorhaben noch in der Frühphase der Umsetzung sind. Es kann also sein, dass da nochmal mehr abgerufen wird jetzt zweitausendachtzehn,
und dass aufgrund der Ausgabenhöhe die Aufträge regelmäßig europaweit ausgeschrieben werden müssen, was diesen Prozess natürlich auch verzögert.
Also sehr interessant ist es auf jeden Fall so wie es ausgestellt gestaltet war ein Reinfall. Dann hat Sascha Lobo sich dieser Sache nochmal angenommen und schreibt dazu und jetzt wollte ich jetzt mal Ga der nennt es eben im ein Lobbyproblem. Sagt er also dieses deutsche,
Breitbanddebakel entstand aus der Unwilligkeit,
Kommunikationskonzerne sinnvoll zu regulieren. Sinnvoll regulieren heißt Wettbewerb sicherstellen. Das ist 'ne sinnvolle Regulation. Der AS hat nicht stattgefunden,
hat der Sascha Logo rech.
Total. Das ist auch das Kernproblem.
Das ist das Kernproblem. Die löchrigen Konzepte der Netzneutralität müssen als Lobby getrieben verstanden werden? Ja, selbstverständlich.
Auch das trägt ja dazu bei, dass Fründe abgesteckt werden und äh die Märkte halt so abgegrenzt bleiben, wie sie durch diese Ursprungssituation schon sich heraus entwickelt haben. Genau.
Dann sagt er, man zahlte schon zweitausendfünfzehn in Deutschland für mobile Daten bis zu fünfzig Mal mehr als in Finnland.
Was ein? Ja, das also Regulierung.
Zur Sicherstellung des Wettbewerbs ist Regulierung, zur Sicherstellung ähm akzeptabler Preise für die Konsumenten,
Regulierung, zugunsten einer fortschreitenden Innovation in einem Markt.
Deswegen tut man das. Deswegen äh versucht man Monopole zu vermeiden und immer die Regulation so zu haben, dass Wettbewerb stattfindet. Wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann bekommst du das, was ein Monopol,
ist nämlich minderwertige Qualität zu überhöhten Preisen. Das haben wir auf jeden Fall erfolgreich erreicht in Deutschland.
Äh dann sagt er noch diese EU-Roaming-Gebühren, die abgeschafft wurden für Surfnet telefonieren im Ausland, äh wurde ähm,
Waren hätten schon viele Jahre vorher verhindert werden müssen und abgeschafft werden müssen. Das wurde jahrelang verschleppt
und unter anderem ja, weil am Ende die Abschaffung der Roaming-Gebühren an diese Netzneutralitätsaufweichung wiederum gebunden war, ne? Also, auch da wieder Hirn, wie können wir den bloß irgendwie noch äh was was geben, damit sie irgendwie klarkommen.
Und das Roaming ist ja auch noch nicht komplett abgeschafft, da gibt's ja immer noch Ausnahmen, die wir auch mehrfach diskutiert haben, so mit Grenzüberschreitungen für US, Klimbim und so bisschen nachvollziehbar an manchen
stellen, aber von so wir haben da mal ein Markt in Europa und jetzt Go ähm da sind wir auch noch nicht.
Dann auch noch ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, die politische Forderung, Förderung des Vectoring,
zögerte nicht nur Glasfaseranschlüsse, sondern stellt
noch heute einen riesigen Kontrollvorteil für die Telekom da. Das hat damit zu tun, dass äh wenn du Vectoring machst, da musst du
quasi dir sehr genaue Gedanken über die Frequenzaufteilung machen und das ermöglicht es nicht dass du
wirklich die gesamte Infrastruktur teilst, das heißt da wo Vectoring gemacht wird, muss,
diese letzte Meile, auf der dann tatsächlich DSL gesprochen wird von
einem Anbieter betrieben werden, der wiederum dann nur die Kapazitäten an andere untervermieten kann. Und das wiederum, dieser eine Anbieter ist dann natürlich die deutsche Telekom.
Weil nur sie kann es sein.
Ja und das ist der erste Punkt und manifestierst also wieder die Marktposition der deutschen Telekom. Zweitens, das Vectoring wurde ähm damit äh.
Zum zur Licht durch Kupfertechnologie,
Weil dadurch die deutsche Telekom hier sagt, damit bekommen wir irgendwie hundert oder sogar mehr Mbit durch das Kupfer gepresst, das ist quasi wie Licht.
Ähm gab ja auch diesen schönen Teat von diesem Telekom-Sprecher Vectoring ist Glasfaser,
Das haben wir damals äh die Sendung in der wir das zitiert haben, hieß glaube ich dann auch Krieg ist, Frieden, Vectorings, Glasfaser oder sowas, müssen wir nochmal raussuchen.
Ja
Tja, wunderschön und ähm wir können uns jetzt wirklich anschauen ähm wie äh,
wie wir im im internationalen europäischen Vergleich einfach mal die letzten sind, ne.
Ich will da nochmal was zu sagen, weil ist natürlich in der Debatte etwas schwierig wird, wenn man die Dinge nicht genau fasst, ne? Und gerade auch so diese Aussage Victoring ist Glasfaser. Da ist auch was dran.
Bis zum die Slam geht ähm.
Da ist was dran, weil das ist ja sozusagen die Versorgung, die Netzversorgung bis zum,
vorletzten Anschlusspunkt, ja? Der letzte Anschlusspunkt ist im Haus. Von da geht's in meine Wohnung
und äh man muss auch klar sehen, dass
Ziel, Fiber, Tose und dann gibt's da verschiedene Buchstaben, die man da einsetzen kann, ne? Also entweder genau, also,
die Straße, aufs Gebäude oder ins Haus, ne. Letzteres natürlich der Idealzustand, das wirklich eine Glasfaser in deiner Wohnung ankommt und bis dahin wirklich sozusagen überhaupt nichts äh anderes stattfindet. Das,
wird noch und
das merke ich auch gerade, weil ich mich selber so ein bisschen damit beschäftigt, noch auf viel Widerstand äh stoßen, nicht nur bei den Leuten, die sich fragen, ja, muss ich, brauche ich denn das überhaupt, sondern auch bei Hausbesitzern, kostet mich das was, was habe ich davon
ja? Äh dann kann man lange darüber diskutieren, dass irgendeine Wertsteigerung vorgenommen wird beim Gebäude und so weiter. Äh das wird sicherlich langfristig auch so sein, trotz alledem sind da erstmal Zurückhaltungen. Du hast bauliche Probleme, weil ja unter Umständen so Gebäude auch nicht so ohne Weiteres äh auch jederzeit mal mit geringem Aufwand neu verkabelbar
sind, weil dazu, ne, vielleicht lang aufgeschobene andere Maßnahmen überhaupt erstmal wieder in Angriff genommen werden.
Weißt du, was so eine Neuverglasung kostet.
Neuverglasfaserung. So, äh was ich eigentlich sagen will, ist.
An sich ist das ja an, also an sich finde ich das jetzt auch so falsch nicht,
dass man darüber nachdenkt quasi aus dem was da ist, erstmal das bestmögliche zu machen, zumal es ja eben schon auch ein Glasfaserausbau mit sich bring,
Problem ist nur, dass das eben immer alles durch diese Telekom gechannelt wird und die diese Anschlüsse und,
ist natürlich irgendwie nach unseren Regulierungsregeln auch verpflichtet, ein bisschen unterzuvermieten, et cetera, aber wir sehen halt, dass das.
Kein Markt ist der so richtig kickt und und so richtig in in Wallung kommt
weil einfach im Zweifelsfall die Telekom dann einfach doch zu sehr da den Vorteil hat. Und warum ändert Deutschland nichts daran? Na ja, weil halt einfach ein Großteil der Aktien auch dem Staat gehört und damit eben auch der Rendite immer wieder ins Staatssekretär äh hüpft und quasi der Staat ein Interesse daran hat,
eben, dass die Telekom auch weiterhin platzhirsch bleibt, da viele Gewinne macht, die dann letzten Endes wieder in den Startsäckel fließen. Das mag nicht der einzige Grund sein, aber sie auf jeden Fall Teil des Problems,
Grundsätzlich,
Wie gesagt, fände ich sehr okay, dass man alle möglichen erdenklichen Wege sucht, um überall so schnell wie möglich das Schnellste zu erreichen,
ja? Und das ist halt in den Städten eben vor allem durch diese letzte Meile, äh die manchmal noch nicht mal eine Meile ist ähm behindert.
Würde aber jetzt diese Infrastruktur quasi von vom Staat betrieben werden,
Na, so hätte man hier so eine so ein Amt, was was möglichst unabhängig ist, sagen wir mal, so eine Infrastruktur ähm, ich weiß nicht, ob Amt, überhaupt das Richtige bezeichnen oder Agentur würde man das wahrscheinlich heute nennen, ja.
Agentur für Infrastruktur.
Ja, warum nicht?
So, also wenn man, wenn man eine eine relativ freigehaltene äh Agentur, die sozusagen jetzt für diesen Betrieb dieser Infrastrukturen erforderlich ist und letzten Endes nichts anderes macht, als sie zu planen, auszubauen, um sie dann sofort dem Markt anzubieten
die also sozusagen auf gar keinen Fall eigene Dienste anbietet. Ja, also ich sage nicht, der Staat soll mir das Internet geben,
der soll nur Infrastrukturen ausbauen und das vor allem in kritischen Stellen,
Also überall überall da, wo man eine schwierige Monepoligopol-Situation hat, das betrifft sowohl Teile der Stadt als auch eben.
Schlecht erreichbare Gegenden, Dörfer, et cetera, da wirft der Staat dann direkt die Kohle rein und dann, jetzt komme ich auch wieder hier auf unser Thema.
Dann kann es auch irgendwie nicht passieren, dass auf einmal vierhundert Millionen Euro, die zum Ausgeben da sind, irgendwie nur zu fünf Millionen abgerufen werden, weil man könnte halt einfach sofort loslegen
So und dann baut man halt einfach diese Glasfaser irgendwie äh bis ins letzte äh äh Nest in Deutschland, dass sie überhaupt keinen Grund, warum nicht jedes Pissdorf in diesem Land
'ne Glasfaser haben sollte, gibt's einfach überhaupt
gar keinen guten Grund dafür, das schaffen andere Länder auch und haben diese Situation teilweise jetzt auch schon. Und äh.
Da kommt man dann eben auch hin. Aber dazu müssen wir einfach ganz anders drüber nachdenken
wie unser Telekom-Markt überhaupt funktionieren soll und wir müssen uns davon trennen, dass es hier nur zwei, drei Anbieter gibt, die irgendwie Relevanz haben und dann noch ein paar kleine
Puppeanbieter nebenbei, die einfach keine Chance haben, weil sie sich da halt einfach nicht auf den Markt durchsetzen können, durch Platzhirschgehabe. Und Lobbyio.
LMP zweihundert hat äh Daniel Dummscheidt Berg da auch noch ein bisschen drüber gesprochen und ich erinnere mich, als wir äh mit dem Camp zwanzig fünfzehn in Mildenberg waren,
da äh ein Kilometer weiter aus der Hochspannungsleitung mal eben Glas gepfuscht haben. Äh so einfach ist das natürlich auch nicht, aber wir haben da eben dafür gesorgt,
dass dann irgendwie die äh Lokaljournalisten und Journalistinnen irgendwie sagten so, ja irgendwie ist denn hier mit diesem Internet, ist irgendwie so schnell bei euch und so. Ich habe dann das hingekriegt. Ja, wir haben ja so und so viel Gigabit und die so, hm.
Und da waren die natürlich sehr interessiert, wie kann dort dann.
Wie geht denn das? Wie geht das? Das so ein paar Nerds einfach auf der Wiese.
Wo kam das denn her? Ja, da oben aus der Hochspannungsleitung haben wir eine Glasfaser geholt. Ja,
interessant, wir dachten immer, es wäre hier irgendwie technisch nicht möglich und dann wussten wir eben
Als wir dann abgereist sind, musste das natürlich auch wieder abgebaut werden und dann standen die da irgendwie so in ihrem Dorf und gucken so, kommen die wenigstens in vier Jahren wieder.
Ich habe noch was zum runterladen.
Ja und ähnliches ist es halt auch mit dem LTE-Ausbau, ja? Also, dass wir im äh Glasfaser äh weit hinten sind im internationalen Vergleich
da war ja auch schon, glaube ich, ein paar Mal angesprochen worden, da habe ich nochmal in in den Links auch nochmal ein schöne
kleine äh Statistik, die auch nochmal aufzeigt, wie es so im Mobilfunkbereich aussieht, da sind wir dann mittlerweile auf Platz zweiunddreißig.
Sechsunddreißig. Zweiunddreißig von sechsunddreißig. Ja.
Steht das da?
Sechsunddreißig europäische Länder, achtundachtzig Länder weltweit. Ach so. Und ich glaube, das ist der also in im Text dazu steht.
Na ja richtig, davon sechsunddreißigsten Europastunden, das war jetzt hier so grau auf grau.
Das ist geil.
Ja, ne? Und zwar letztes Quartal zwanzig siebzehn hier als Maßgabe und äh Deutschland ist wirklich erschreckend weit hinten. Also es ist wirklich albern und äh auch vor allem überhaupt nicht mehr nachvollziehbar.
Also ne, an für die Liste wird angeführt von den Niederlanden. Natürlich auch ein relativ wenig Fläche beinhaltendes Land. Die erreichen,
durchschnittliche durchschnittlichen Down Stream unter vier G von zweiundvierzig Mbit.
Also das Argument, das Land ist klein, gilt nicht, weil ein kleines Land hat auch weniger Ressourcen, also.
Na ja, die Niederlande haben jetzt nicht so wenig Ressourcen, ne, die sind internet, da sind die sind wirtschaftlich, geht's denen gerade ganz gut.
Ja, während Deutschland ja wirtschaftlich total hinterherhängt.
Offenbar.
Ein Scheiß.
Also zweiundvierzig Mbit, down durchschnittlicher Downstream und neunundachtzig Prozent Verfügbarkeit von LTE, ja,
während wir in Deutschland knapp die Hälfte durchschnittliche zweiundzwanzig Mbit Down Stream im 4G Netz haben und fünfundsechzig Prozent Verfügbarkeit,
Jetzt ist immer noch die Frage, ist die prozentuale Verfügbarkeit auf Fläche gerechnet
oder auf Zeit oder wo der Mensch sich aufhält, müsste man sich nochmal genau die Erhebung von Open Signal anschauen, aber es ist relativ klar, dass hier eine Messmethode gewählt wurde, die eben ähm.
Relativ klar äh klare Ergebnisse zeigt und wo unter den unter den ersten zehn,
nicht ein einziger unter fünfundsiebzig Prozent Verfügbarkeit kommt. Der Durchschnitt ist eher irgendwie über achtzig Prozent Verfügbarkeit in den Top Ten, ja? Und wir krepeln damit fünfundsechzig Prozent Verfügbarkeit einher, es ist wirklich,
sehr traurig und das sind in dieser Statistik ist irgendwie Bulgarien an Stelle fünf Serbien an Stelle sieben Kroatien an Stelle acht und Deutschland anstelle zweiunddreißig.
Hinter uns ist Georgien, Polen, Russland und Weißrussland.
Polen, wer immer, wenn ich in Polen bin, habe ich großartigen Empfang.
Ja, ich auch, aber das mag auch äh regional eingeschränkt sein.
Beschränkt sein.
Oder mittlerweile nur noch für Ausländer, man weiß es ja nicht. Nicht, dass die Polen jetzt an Informationen kommen.
Also ihr merkt euch, ihr könnt eigentlich in jedes andere Land fahren, fährt ein besseres Internet haben. Macht nur einen Bogen um Georgien, Polen, Russland und Weiß, Russland.
Genau, die Nichtverfügbarkeit von Internet erkennt ihr am D.
Oder auch Raute D.
Genug geratet. Oder haben wir noch was zum Raten.
Nein, Tim, jetzt nur noch gute Nachrichten. Eine ewige Diskussion, meine Güte, ist das, das ist so all das Thema. Ähm.
Es gab früher einen Webseitenbetreiber unter dem Namen Kino TO. Ähm,
Und die haben folgendes gemacht, die haben ihre haben eine Seite vollgepflastert mit,
Werbung haben da drauf Videostreams angeboten von in der Regel auf illegalem Wege erlangen,
Aufzeichnung von Kinofilmen oder auch an Serien oder sonstigem und haben dann quasi diese,
diese Raubkopien dort gestreamt. Das streamt, die Streams kamen wiederum von irgendwo anders her und waren da nur eingebettet und da die Refinanzierung war, weil das ganze Ding einfach mit irgendwelcher Werbung von oben bis unten vollgekleistert war
haben damit einen ganz guten Umsatz gemacht und haben sich die
Filmstudios selbstverständlich zum Feind gemacht. Kino TO wurde irgendwann geratzt. Das muss
was weiß ich, zweitausendzehn, zweitausendelf gewesen sein. Da habe ich nämlich damals die Berichterstattung bei Netzpolitik Org drüber gemacht, daran erinnere ich mich noch und ähm.
Dann äh kam natürlich nächste Tag Kino X Punkt TO,
äh und hat quasi das das Erbe angetreten und diese Leute sind jetzt ähm,
Sage ich mal, deren Geschäftsmodell ist nicht das sympathischste, ne? Die haben irgendwie werden finanziert mit aus relativ mit relativ dubiosen Werbeanzeigen. Da wird auch das ein oder andere Mal Mywear äh Werbeanzeige
gesichtet, die zu irgendwelcher Installationswillichtiger Software auffordert und ähm zumindest bei der bei der Ermittlung und äh,
bei den Verfahren gegen Kino TO wurde eben auch ein ähm.
Ein Netzwerk entdeckt, wo sie quasi geschäftsmäßig tatsächlich die Beschaffung dieser Filme organisiert haben und dafür bezahlt haben. Also das wird jetzt ja immer nicht die die
tieffreundlichen,
Heimpiraten, die Pertorent mal einen Film teilen, sondern das sind Leute, die sich da auch tatsächlich dran bereichern. Äh die Uhr äh die Urheberrechte anderer zu verletzen.
Allerdings auch denke ich eigentlich handelt es sich dabei um ein ähm.
Wirklich inzwischen vernachlässigbares Geschäftsmodell, da wir ja mit ähm.
Mit Netflix, Amazon, Streaming und wen es da nicht alles gibt. Inzwischen sehr einfache, niedrigschwellige und erschwingliche Angebote zum Streaming von,
Inhalten in hoher Qualität haben. Nichtsdestotrotz äh hat sich die Konstantin Film.
In ihren Rechten verletzt gesehen und mittels einer einstweiligen Verfügung darauf hingewirkt, dass es
eine Sperrung von Kino X Punkt EU im Vodafone-Netz gibt, welcher erlassen wurde vom Landgericht München am ersten Februar zweitausendachtzehn.
Vodafone hat dazu erklärt, es geht
Um urheberrechtliche Ansprüche der Content Konstantin filmen die Durchtritte verletzt worden sind, äh weitere Details nennt, wo davon nicht, äh weil es sich noch um ein laufendes Verfahren handelt und
seit neunten Februar. Haben sie diese Sperre und zwar nur im Festnetz und nicht im Mobilfunk. Ähm gleichzeitig.
Stellt sich natürlich immer die Frage, eine Internetseite sperren, da geht doch gar nicht, wie macht ihr das denn, ne? Und es handelt sich hier um eine DNS-Sperre, das heißt, wenn der Vodafone DNS Server gefragt wird.
Gib doch mal bitte die IP-Adresse von Kino X Punkt O.
Dann antwortet er mit. Einmal hier entlang und gibt also dann eine Vodafone eigene Domain an.
Die wiederum weiterleitet auf äh Vodafone dot com. Äh Vodafone DE Slash Webblog HTML oder irgendwie steht, äh hier wird es gerade hier mal gerade nicht. Hier ist gerade gesperrt
Äh das heißt, wer äh diese Sperre umgehen möchte, nutzt äh einen anderen DNS-Server,
kriegt dann wieder die richtige Antwort und kann auch wieder auf die Seite zugreifen. Also eine hm.
Sehr äh fehlerhafte Form der Sperrung,
Wie eben nur ein DNS-Server betrifft, die man also mit sehr, die sehr einfach zum Gehen ist und die gleichzeitig aber viele Nutzer betrifft.
Und ähm hierzu gibt es jetzt auch seit mindestens zehn Jahren zu dem zu dieser gesamten Idee der DNS-Sperren eine Zensur, Solardebatte und so weiter. Die zentrale,
Forderung, Verhängnis da um illegale Inhalte geht, dann bitteschön,
Gerichtlich dagegen vorgehen und zwar gegen die Betreiber und diese Inhalte,
löschen oder entfernen, statt sie zu sperren, zentral ist diese Forderung insbesondere. Ihr nimmt Zusammenhang mit ähm sagen wir mal,
schwer kriminellen und illegalen Inhalten und nicht nur Inhalten, die irgendwie die Rechte von Konzernen verletzen, also damals entzündete sich die Debatte am Dokumentierten.
Kindesmissbrauch und wurden damals äh herangeführt von Ursula von der Leyen, die damals noch Familienministerin war. Das muss alles so zweitausendneun oder sowas. Zweitausendneun, zweitausendzehn gewesen sein oder so.
Altes Thema, schade, dass diese diese Methode eben nicht,
klein zu kriegen ist. Interessanterweise rannten sich dann auch noch Gerichte darum, Vodafone würde die Daten speichern der Menschen, die also auf diese Sperrseite zugreifen. Dazu äh hat äh Vodafone dann äh,
Thomas Rudel geantwortet, Vodafone speichert grundsätzlich nur die Daten, die das Unternehmen zu Apric,
Abrechnungszwecken benötigt. Dabei hält Vodafone die gesetzlichen Höchstgrenzen zur Speicherdauer strikt ein und unterschreitet diese im Sinne der Datensparsparsamkeit,
auf freiwilliger Basis zum Teil deutlich. Port und IP-Adressen werden im Mobilfunk gar nicht und im Bereich Festnetz nur für sieben Tage gespeichert. Das Gesetz zur erneuten Einführung einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
mit einer Speicherung dieser Daten. Für zehn Wochen ist basierend auf Entscheidungen des EuGH sowie des Verwaltungsgerichts Keulen als Europarechtswidrig eingestuft worden
und wird von Vodafone nicht angewendet. Das ist äh eine interessante, schöne Nebennachricht, weil dieses Urteil des Verwaltungsgerichts Köln haben wir damals sehr gefeiert.
Da war die Frage, ob das auch wirklich sich bei den Providern niederschlägt und hier gibt, Vodafone eben an, ja, tut es. Einsweilige Verfügung hat Vodafone jetzt erlangt, der Ärger ist also hier eher dabei, dass er dafür die für diese unsinnige Sperrmethode,
'ne Rechtsgrundlage haben und dass diese jetzt auch Anwendung findet.
Wir sind immer noch nicht durch, oder?
Aber jetzt ist es wirklich nur eine Kurzmeldung. Ähm.
Der Clanamswang bei Facebook bleibt illegal
auch interessant, ja? Also diese diese schreiende Ungerechtigkeit, ja? Facebook verstößt nämlich mit jedem Tag seines Betriebs äh so die Einschätzung eigentlich aller Datenschützer und sonstigen Gelehrten in der Interpretation des Telemediengesetzes gegen
eben jenes, denn das äh TNE Mediengesetz sieht vor, dass ein Anbieter von Onlinediensten.
Äh das Anbieter von Onlinediensten, die Nutzung und Bezahlung ihrer Angebote anonym oder unter Pseudonom ermöglichen müssen, soweit dies technisch möglich und zumutbar ist,
Und das ist natürlich bei Facebook der Fall. Facebooks Funktionalität ist in keiner Form daran gebunden,
dass man dort unter einem Realnamen agiert. Dennoch,
ähm hat Facebook in seinen äh AGBs einen Realnamen Zwang und sagt äh.
Du du musst deine richtigen muss unterrichtigen Namen agieren, du darfst keine falschen persönlichen Informationen bereitstellen und du musst deine Kontaktdaten auf aktuellem und neuesten Stand halten.
Also wenn du dich umbenennst oder umziehst oder sonstiges, dann musst du das auch hier einpflegen und damit bist du quasi äh durch deren AGB dazu verpflichtet, dort als Realperson diesen Datensatz zu pflegen.
Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband hat da in sechsundzwanzig Punkten geklagt und das Gericht hat jetzt lediglich festgestellt, dass diese Klarnamen der Regelung in ihrer aktuellen Fassung aus anderen Gründen ohnehin ähm,
Äh rechtswidrig sei eben wegen dieser Verpflichtung ähm ähm.
Zu korrekten persönlichen Daten und gleichzeitig die Einwilligung zur Verarbeitung der Daten. Äh die damit einhergeht. Ja also,
irgendein blödes Paragraphengereite wieder, was jetzt dazu geführt hat, dass es irgendein halbgares Urteil gibt, was auf irgendeiner niedrigen Ebene ähm
gefällt wurde, sechsundzwanzig Punkte insgesamt behandelt und gegen das jetzt sowohl Facebook als auch der Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband äh in Berufung,
gehen werden. Das heißt, dieses Urteil wird uns noch länger beschäftigen, aber es ist auch interessant, wie lange,
Über wie viele Jahrzehnte man in Deutschland ein ein offensichtlich gesetzwiesiges Angebot unterhalten kann.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, wie lange sie das noch durchziehen.
Und jetzt endlich sind wir bei den Terminen.
Am Samstag, dem einundzwanzigsten April zweitausendachtzehn findet der siebzehnte Augsburger Linux Infotag in den Räumen der Hochschule Augsburg statt
Besucherinnen können sich über Linux und Open Source Software informieren. Außerdem geht es um digitale Gesellschaft, kreative Anwendungen von Technikwissenschaft,
Bildung. Es gibt einen CFP, wo ihr herzlich eingeladen seid, euch auch dran zu beteiligen.
Aber auch im Norden äh nee, stimmt ja gar nicht, ist ja gar nicht im Norden, ist ja auch im Süden äh aber zumindest zu Ostern gibt's auch noch eine weitere
die man einplanen kann, der
wartet, das ist ja so ein bisschen der Wanderpokal der CCC Veranstaltung dieses Mal geht's nach Würzburg ins Vogelconvention Center äh,
läuft vom neunzehnten bis zum zweiundzwanzigsten April und äh.
Zweitausendneunzehn, aber das ist das so, neunzehnter bis.
Weiß nicht, du hast das dahin geschrieben, was weiß ich, wann Ostern ist.
Weil ich weiß, Ostern halt, christlich muss man nochmal nachgucken.
Das gehört zum Service. Man muss auch nachgucken, wann Ostern ist.
Fass ich doch nicht, wann Ostern ist.
Wer weiß schon, wann Ostern ist. Das ist immer so eine Sache, ne?
Nein, dreißigster dritter bis zweiter vierter zwanzig achtzehn.
Lass mich hier auslaufen, ne?
Zweiundzwanzigste. Ich wollte nur mal gucken, ob du aufpasst.
Ja ja so so bist du zu mir, ne? Alright. Also irgendwie Ende März.
Ende März bis Anfang Ap.
Dahin fahren, gibt wieder ein paar Tickets, kann man rumhängen, kann man hacken, kann man Spaß haben, kann man Leute kennenlernen und vielleicht auch nochmal Würzburg anschauen, wenn man das noch nicht kennt.
Und dann vom zehnten bis dreizehnten Mai zweitausendachtzehn findet die achtzehnte Gulasch-Programmiernacht statt. Wie immer im ZKM,
und äh auch da äh gibt es jetzt Tickets und ein CFP, an dem wir euch herzlich einladen, euch zu beteiligen.
Zittkeim wie immer.
Ist doch, weiß ich nicht, wie vielen Jahren jetzt da ging direkt bei der General beim Generalbundesanwalt im Garten.
Ich war zweimal da. Beim ersten Mal war es noch woanders, aber wer weiß. Ich weiß nichts. Äh ich schaff's immer nicht, äh Pfingsten, schwieriger Termin für mich. Jedes Jahr.
Jetzt muss ich gucken, seit wann die GPN im ZKM ist, das ist aber doch jetzt schon länger.
Na ja, du bist ja, du bist ja jung, du. Hast ja.
Ja äh achtzehn Mal war ich nicht da. Seit zweitausend äh zweitausendfünfzehn scheint sie dort zu sein. Ne, vorher auch schon.
Vielleicht war es auch nur die Erste, da hingehen wir auf jeden Fall noch woanders rum. Ist ja auch egal. Äh,
Sind alles so Nordveranstaltungen. Wenn ihr noch andere schöne Termine habt und vielleicht auch noch welche, die noch ein bisschen mehr auch in die netzpolitische äh Spezialisierung hineinlagen, dann her damit. Wir haben jetzt in letzter Zeit relativ wenig,
Termine erhalten. Ich weiß nicht genau, woran das liegt, ob ihr uns misstraut, ob ihr das Gefühl habt, wir haben hier nicht die passende Reichweite,
oder sind wir einfach nicht würdig, eure Veranstaltungen anzusagen.
Äh es ist glaube ich also wir sind da ähm.
Vielleicht nehmen die Veranstaltungen auch Schaden, dadurch, dass wir sie ankündig.
Kann er auch sein. Das sind die merkwürdigsten Verschwörungstheori.
Nein, ey, nicht die sind jetzt diese Hacker da wieder, diese Nerds, ey, lasst mir in Ruhe, ich gehe lieber, wohin denn dann?
Wo willst du denn so? Wo willst du denn da hingehen? Hier kommt doch eh nirgendwo rein. Nein, aber es ist doch, nein, schickt uns eure Empfehlung. Zum Beispiel diesen Linux-Tag, äh, Linux-Infotag in Augsburg, der war mir auch gar nicht bekannt.
Nun denn endet eine viel zu lange Sendung aber vielleicht ist er auch gar nicht viel zu lan.
Wir wir lernen daraus, es ist halt einfach echt problematisch, wenn man das auslässt eine Woche. Es gilt recht sich. Es rechts sich.
So ist das. Kommt immer wieder alles zurück. So und jetzt?
Ja, damit danke ich dem Dirk, dem Sebastian, der Konstanze, dem Sören, dem Volkmar, dem Christian und dem Niklas. Und entlasse euch.
Fristlos.
Zurück ins Internet.
Und ich denke danke allen anderen, die äh gespendet haben, die äh kommentiert haben, Feedback geleistet haben, Anregungen haben oder uns auch nur bei irgendwelchen Gelegenheiten mitgeteilt haben, dass sie uns hören
Und ähm sagt's weiter, bleibt wacker,
hoffe, dass nächste Woche wieder eine Sendung kommt. Inständig geht auf die Knie, bietet.
Und äh wer seine Kommentare lieber in mündlicher Form einreicht, für den haben wir ja immer noch unsere Hotline geschaltet. Die null drei null einhundertzwanzig achtundachtzig.
Drei acht und achtzig.
Oh, es wird Zeit, dass wir die Sendung beenden.
Aber nicht ohne letzte Worte.